Und damit herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen Chaosradio hier im Blumenau Fritz, das jeden zweiten Monat am Ende des Monats an einem Donnerstag hier stattfindet und wo Leute aus dem Chaos Computer Club und dem weiteren und näheren Umfeld hier ins Studio kommen, um uns über Dinge aufzuklären und zu erzählen, die mit dem großen, weiten Internet zu tun haben und den neuen Rundfunk Empfangsgeräten, die wir alle bei uns dabei tragen. Es geht oft um Netz, es geht oft um Netzpolitik und es geht heute um ein Thema, das möglicherweise nicht so ganz unbekannt ist. Zwei Jahre rund begleitet es uns jetzt schon und das sind die Leaks des Herrn Snowden. Vor zwei Jahren war es ungefähr so weit, dass jemand ankam und gesagt hat, so hier, ich habe da mal ein paar Dokumente aus einem Geheimdienst herausgetragen und sage euch jetzt mal, wie ihr alles überwacht werdet. Das ist einerseits, hat uns das begleitet in den letzten Jahren, das ist immer präsent gewesen. Andererseits ist es jetzt schon so lange her und fast schon Historie, dass man auch mal gucken kann, wie war das eigentlich, wie ist das eigentlich und was wird daraus eigentlich. Und das wollen wir heute hier klären und dazu habe ich, wie immer zu einem Chaosradio, viele, viele Gäste hier im Studio. Es ist zum einen Anne Roth, hallo und guten Abend. Hallo. Sie ist für die Fraktion Die Linke Referentin für den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Habe ich das richtig zusammengefasst? Sehr schön. Was das genau ist, klären wir heute noch. Dann ist der Andre Meister vom Blog Netzpolitik Org, hallo und guten Abend.
Hallihallo.
Der, den man vielleicht auch am ehesten kennt, wenn man die Berichterstattung verfolgt, weil er in diesem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss sitzt und da immer bloggt. Live und dann auch später noch. Und außerdem noch Linus Neumann vom Cars Computer Club.
Guten Abend.
Die, die ja auch irgendwas mit Internet machen, habe ich gehört, manchmal.
Ja, wir haben versucht, das auszusitzen, aber...
So, wir wollen heute mal über zwei Jahre Snowden und was davon übrig blieb reden. Und ich würde das gerne wie in so einer kleinen Geschichtsstunde anfangen und fragen, wie das eigentlich damals, das ist ja wirklich zwei Jahre, ist ja wirklich so eine sehr lange Zeit, gerade in Internetrechnung. Wie war das damals für euch, als es war ja so, es kam an einem Tag, so ein Video, wo so ein Typ in einem Hotel saß, das überall hätte sein können, angeblich in Hongkong war und dann erzählte, ja, ich habe hier so ein paar Daten rausgetragen vom US-amerikanischen Geheimdienst. Dann gab es so einen kleinen Artikel, der gesagt hat, ja, da gibt es so ein bisschen Überwachung und dann ging es immer so weiter. Wie war das für euch, wie habt ihr das erlebt? Anne, vielleicht fängst du mal an. Kannst du dich, also es gibt ja bei anderen großen Sachen, wo warst du an dem Tag? Kannst du dich noch erinnern? Bei 9-11 wird das total gerne gefragt. Ist das für dich auch so ein großes Ereignis? Kannst du dich noch genau dran erinnern, wie das war?
Nee, kann ich nicht. Also ich kann mich an meine Reaktion erinnern, aber wo ich war und wann ich das jetzt genau gehört habe, das weiß ich nicht mehr. Und die Reaktion so vom ersten oder den ersten Tagen, glaube ich, war, ich habe da noch bei einer NGO gearbeitet, die sich vor allen Dingen damit beschäftigt, anderen Leuten zu helfen, ihre digitale Sicherheit zu verbessern. Das heißt, Anleitungen zu schreiben für verschlüsselte E-Mails und Leuten tatsächlich Tipps zu geben, was wirklich hilft und was nicht. Und wir waren, glaube ich, ganz schön geschockt. Und so im zweiten Moment, würde ich sagen, setzte so ein bisschen das Entsetzen ein, auch, oh Scheiße, es ist alles kaputt. Wir wissen im Grunde nicht mehr so richtig, was wir den Leuten jetzt raten können. Wir müssen eigentlich alles, was wir bisher Leuten empfohlen haben, nochmal überprüfen und das wird nicht einfach werden. Das war so die erste Reaktion.
War das gleich am Anfang so? Also gleich, ich würde sagen, mit diesem kurzen Videofilm, mit diesem ersten Artikel, dass dir gleich die ganze Tragweite klar war?
Also Wochen hat das nicht gedauert. Ob das jetzt gleich am ersten Tag war, kann ich nicht genau sagen, aber schon ziemlich schnell im Grunde war gewissermaßen die Tür auf und du wusstest alles, was du immer schon geahnt hast und gehofft hast, dass es nicht wirklich stimmt, dass es jetzt wirklich war. Also und damit war die Tragweite vielleicht nicht in allen Facetten. Da kamen schon noch ein paar Schockmomente hinterher, aber schon ziemlich schnell klar. Scheiße, das ist jetzt richtig dick.
Andre, wie war es bei dir?
Also ich kann mich tatsächlich noch erinnern, wo ich war. Kann ich dann mal später meinen Kindern erzählen. Wir bei Netzpolitik Org, wir berichten ja über die ganzen Themen schon eine ganze Weile, schon ein bisschen länger als Edward Snowden auch bei der NSA war. Und wir hatten am 5. Juni, da ging es ja los, mit der ersten Enthüllung, dass der amerikanische Mobilfunkanbieter Verizon massenhaft Metadaten von der Telefonkommunikation direkt an die NSA übermittelt, und zwar von allen Gesprächen, die da stattfinden. Und da haben wir natürlich drüber berichtet, haben gesagt, ja, das ist das, was bei uns mit Vorratssattenspeicherung gemacht werden soll. Hatten das aber die Enthüllung als Einzelfall erst noch gesehen, weil es war ja noch gar nicht klar, dass dahinter was viel Größeres stand und dass es da einen Leaker gibt, der Dutzende, Hunderttausende Dokumente mitgenommen hat und wie das ausgehen würde. Und dann irgendwie am Tag drauf kam diese große Meldung Prism. Die NSA hat direkten Zugriff auf die großen amerikanischen Internetunternehmen, Google, Microsoft, Apple, Facebook und so weiter und so fort. Und gerade den Artikel noch vor mir, den ich damals geschrieben habe, da stand drin, ja, Glenn Greenwald, nach dem Scoop gestern mit der Vorratssattenspeicherung, der ja schon mal echt krass war, legt ja noch einen drauf und hat schon wieder so ein internes NSA-Dokument, voll krass da jetzt endlich mal ranzukommen und zu wissen, was dieser größte, geheimste Geheimdienst macht, weil wir haben es immer geahnt und die Enthüllungsjournalisten und Spezialisten, die haben das immer schon so ein bisschen gesagt, aber bisher hat sich da niemand so wirklich dafür interessiert. Und dann, dass in den nächsten Tagen, Wochen auch mit dem kleinen Video, das Laura Poitras da in Hongkong im Hotel von Edward gefilmt hat, wurde dann das ganze Ausmaß überhaupt erst mal deutlich krass, das ist echt, der hat einen riesen Stapel an Dokumenten mitgenommen und da wird noch viel mehr kommen von den zwei Meldungen, die wir ohnehin schon sehr beeindruckend und ziemlich groß erachtet haben. Und dann ist immer mehr gekommen. Das hat ja nicht aufgehört bis heute. Seit zwei Jahren wird mindestens einmal die Woche ein neues Dokument ausgewertet und wieder einmal denkt man, krass, das machen die auch.
Da würde ich auf jeden Fall auch noch gerne aus Füchern sprechen wollen, dieses sagen, wie einfach ist es oder wie krass ist es jetzt immer noch und wie lange kann es das noch bleiben. Aber erst mal Linus, wie war es bei dir?
Ich war eigentlich am Anfang underwhelmed. Also so dieses Telefondaten mitschneiden, da habe ich mir sogar gedacht, ja ach. Und dann fing es an mit, ja und eure Daten von Facebook werden von den Geheimdiensten eingesehen. Das war ja dann so Prism. Da habe ich auch noch gesagt, nein, wirklich jetzt. Jetzt erzählt uns aber einer wirklich ganz was Neues. Und als es klar wurde, dass das jetzt nur mal so der Anfang war für den allgemeinen Paukenschlag und dass das zwei Jahre weitergehen würde, dann habe ich irgendwie langsam gemerkt, was das wirklich jetzt bedeuten würde. Aber interessant wurde es für mich eigentlich immer erst, als es um die internationalen Verstrickungen ging. Erst da fing so ein Teil an, wo ich mich nicht mehr bemühen musste, so vom Told-you-so wegzugehen zu einem Bemühtsein, um schockiert sein und auf dieser Welle vielleicht irgendwie auch als Aktivist zu reiten zu dem Teil, der sich halt irgendwann auch wirklich selber schockiert und echt angetrittet war.
Das war am Anfang für dich wirklich so, dass du dachtest, ja gut, das haben wir jetzt eher immer gewusst, jetzt sagt es halt mal jemand, aber so besonders ist es eigentlich nicht.
Na, es setzt sich schon irgendwann so, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es so krass ist. Ich weiß, wir hatten auch glaube ich im Chaosradio dann noch über diese Untersee-Kabel-Operation und so gesprochen. Da hat man dann irgendwann gemerkt, dass die da wirklich nicht nur sportliche, sondern eher so Extremsport-Ambitionen haben. Da habe ich auch noch mal um meine eigene Sicherheit noch mal mir mehr Sorgen gemacht. Aber wie gesagt, am Anfang war ich echt nicht so schockiert, wie ich es eigentlich jetzt immer mehr werde. Also für mich wird der Schock eigentlich immer größer mit jedem Tag.
Was ist denn für dich die krasseste oder sozusagen zwei Jahre jede Woche? Das ist halt unglaublich viel. Man kann es gar nicht mehr so richtig auseinanderhalten. Gibt es sozusagen so ein, zwei oder drei Sachen, wo du sagst, okay, das sind echt die krassesten Dinger?
Also am krassesten fand ich Angry Birds. Weil das ist halt echt so, ich meine, da ist echt ganz klar.
Was war das nochmal?
Dass sie im Prinzip die Spiele, Server und Accounts von Angry Birds Spielern irgendwie mit überwacht haben oder von diesen Angry Birds Servern. Und da habe ich mir halt gedacht, okay, da ist irgendwie ein Bereich, also das ist sowas von offenkundig absolut irrelevant und sie sammeln es trotzdem. Das war so dieser, das hat mich eigentlich am meisten Angst gemacht. Dass man, also selbst in Bereichen, wo es völlig unsinnig ist, da noch irgendwelche Daten zu sammeln, tun sie es trotzdem. Und da habe ich gedacht, okay, scheiße, hier haben wir es wirklich mit Irren zu tun.
Und gab es auch technischen Punkt, wo du gesagt hast, so, oh krass, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass sie keine Ahnung, das geknackt haben oder dass sie so und so vorgehen? Oder war das eh alles bekannt, dass es theoretisch möglich ist und dann haben sie es halt auch praktisch umgesetzt?
Also ich würde sagen, die waren so in der Regel ungefähr 20 Prozent über meiner Schätzung. Also sie waren schon immer drüber, aber auch selten in dem Bereich, wo ich echt dachte, okay, das hätte ich mir jetzt nicht theoretisch zumindest noch vorstellen.
Also die Autos sind ein bisschen schneller gefahren, als du gedacht hattest, aber es waren keine fliegenden Surfboards.
Ich kann mich jetzt gerade an keins erinnern, aber vielleicht ein andere Beispiel, wo ich sage, ha, doch halt!
Na noch haben wir nichts über ihre Quantencomputer. Ja, wenn sie die dann irgendwann mal haben, weil die NSA ist ja so fünf bis zehn Jahre vor der allgemeinen Forschung, was wir jetzt auch noch mal lernen könnten, ja dann ist wirklich Essig mit fast aller unserer Verschlüsselungen, die wir bisher haben.
Ist das tatsächlich was, was man jetzt aus den ganzen Snowdinks rausziehen kann, dass man ungefähr abschätzen kann, wir wissen nicht genau, was sie können, wir wissen aber, wie weit sie uns voraus sind? Okay, das sind diese fünf oder zehn Jahre, von denen du sprachst?
Genau, gegenüber der öffentlichen Forschung an Universitäten.
Was war denn für dich, gab es für dich so ein, okay, das war jetzt total krass oder ist dir im Gedächtnis geblieben, was besonders heftig für dich war?
Also, für mich bleibt die Kernaussage der allen einzelnen Leaks zusammengenommen. Sie nehmen einfach alles, und zwar im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes wirklich alles. Sie reden ja selber davon, collect it all, store it all, search it all und so. Sie kennen keine Grenze nirgendwo, niemand ist unverdächtig. Es wird einfach mal wirklich ein riesigen Datenzentrum. Die komplette digitale Kommunikation der gesamten Menschheit, gesammelt, gerastet und ausgewertet. Bis hin zu Angry Birds. Und das haben wir in den vielen Einzeldokumenten. Jetzt dieses Gesamtbild, ob es Glasfaserleitungen, Hecken von Technikroutern, also wirklich jede Technologie, die sie ja denken können. Sie sind drin und sie nutzen es.
Hast du irgendwas, wo du denkst, okay, das hat mich jetzt besonders überrascht, was dir noch in Erinnerung ist?
Leider nicht so im Detail. Ich habe mir ein super schlechtes Gewicht gedacht, was so Details angeht. Aber ich weiß diese eine Geschichte, wo sie, wenn man irgendwelche Sachen bestellt, dann sich sozusagen dazwischenschalten und irgendwie die tolle Hardware, die... Stimmt.
Was war denn das? Das war auf dem Chaos-Kongress, auf dem ersten Kongress, nach dem Stone Leaks, wo du das in einem Vortrag auch mal ausführlicher erzählt hast, dass du immer so einen Computer bestellst, und sie fangen den ab und bauen da Teile ein.
Da hatte ich den Eindruck, als das rauskam, da hatten echt eine ganze Menge eine blasse Nase.
Das fand ich auch echt unschön. Da gab es auch eine so eine Geschichte, wo ich es spannend fand, weil es gab ja immer diesen Effekt, so ja, wir haben euch ja gesagt, dass ihr überwacht werdet, und jetzt wird es mal richtig gesagt, aber wo so irre Verschwörungstheorien auf einmal real wurden. Es gab irgendwie diese Geschichte von, dass sie an Monitorkabel oder Tastaturkabel so kleine Geräte dranbauen, die man dann von bis zu Kilometern weit weg mit Mikrowellen bestrahlt und dann die Daten auslesen kann. Und es gibt ja tatsächlich so Irre, die so, ja, die Regierung bestrahlt uns mit Mikrowellen, um uns abzuhorchen. Auf einmal ist das sozusagen Realität und ich denke so, was zur Hölle passiert da? Das sind auf jeden Fall die Sachen. Ich würde gerne gleich über die Technikkomponente nochmal ausführlicher reden, aber eine Frage, zudem Snowden selbst noch, weil der war ja für mich erschienend, und dann war der eigentlich da, war der für euch von Anfang an glaubwürdig? Oder habt ihr jemals gedacht so, naja gut, ich meine, irgendwie so diese Powerpoint-Präsentation, die das meistens ja waren, die kann man sich auch selber zusammenklicken. War das jemals irgendwie im Zweifel, dass der echt ist?
Ja, doch, klar. Also ich meine, die Frage hat sich, also weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber ich habe mir die schon gestellt, woher will ich mir denn da jetzt sicher sein, dass das nicht irgendwer sich ausgedacht, ich fand, also so von der Prozentzahl her würde ich sagen, war das jetzt nicht überwiegend, dieser Zweifel, aber so das Fragezeichen, das habe ich schon ab und zu mal im Kopf gehabt.
Aber schon abgelegt oder ist es noch da?
Nee, nee, also für mich ist das weg. Also 100 Prozent ist bei mir selten irgendwas, aber also im Grunde ist es weg und ja.
Ich hatte das tatsächlich selten bis nie, denn auch bei unserer Arbeit auf Netzpolitik müssen wir natürlich Quellen checken, gegenchecken. Und wenn ich irgendwas irgendwo anders im Internet lese, dann frage ich mich natürlich erst mal, wie plausibel ist das? Wo haben die das her? Welche Quellen zitieren sie? Und Glenn Greenwald und das ganze Team um die Journalisten, die die Dokumente ausgewertet haben, die haben da schon sehr sauber gearbeitet von Anfang an, haben auch immer dazugeschrieben, dass sie die Quellen verifiziert haben. Und was auch ein ziemlich guter Hinweis ist, es hat ja nie irgendjemand dementiert. Die NSA hat ja nie gesagt, machen wir nicht, sondern ihre Ausrede war immer, hm, können wir nicht so ganz genau drüber reden, aber seid euch sicher, wir halten uns an Recht und Gesetz. Und sukzessive sind ja dann auch durch weitere, durch Ausschichten, durch Gerichtsverfahren und so weiter und so fort immer mehr Details ans Licht gekommen, wo dann die Dinge nur noch mehr bestätigt wurden. Es gibt dann Detailfragen mit ein paar Nerds da draußen, welche Details jetzt in der Interpretation oder Glaubwürdigkeit einiger Personen sind. Aber die Dokumente selbst hat nie jemand angezweifelt.
Na, ich denke, also auch an den diplomatischen Reaktionen der USA konnte man relativ schnell erkennen, dass das jetzt kein Scherzbold ist. Also dieses Flugzeug von Evo Morales, was dann mal irgendwie zwischen landen musste.
Und das war der Präsident von? Bolivien, der sozusagen in Europa unterwegs war. Und dann wurde er, also er wurde nicht direkt zum Landen gezwungen, sondern man hat ihm das Überflugverbot für die Länder, wo er drüber fliegen wollte, nicht erteilt.
Und dann hat er keinen Sprit.
Genau, und dann musste er glaube ich in der Schweiz irgendwie sozusagen zwischen landen. Und das war schon diplomatisch, klar.
Und also das ist halt, das war eine Aktion, wo du gesehen hast, okay, die USA haben jetzt nicht nur ein bisschen Sorge, sondern die haben, die sind jetzt auch echt bereit irgendwie zum Äußersten zu gehen. Und natürlich auch in der Verfolgung Edward Snowdens in den Tagen, bis er dann irgendwann seinen sicheren Hafen ausgerechnet in Russland gefunden hat. An den Reaktionen hat man relativ schnell gesehen, dass der Mann keine Scherze macht.
Das ist sozusagen so der Einstieg in die Snowden-Leaks. Wenn ihr übrigens selber dazu was sagen wollt oder ein Fazit ziehen wollt, könnt auch gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110 und vielleicht mal selber erzählen, was Snowden für euch verändert hat oder vielleicht ist doch alles gleich geblieben. Das wäre auch nicht uninteressant, wie ihr dazu gekommen seid. Weil ihr jetzt schon inhaltlicher vor allen Dingen darum ging, dass ihr gesagt habt, ja es sind alle Überwachungsfantasien oder Albträume, die wir hatten, damit wahr geworden. Das ist ja ein spannendes Ding, weil forst Snowden habe ich das immer so beobachtet, wenn man Leuten, die nichts damit zu tun haben, die sich nicht für das Thema interessiert, versucht hat, von Verschlüsselungstechnologien zu überzeugen. Dann sagen die ja immer, naja ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen und dahinter, also das Argument gibt es immer noch, aber dahinter schwingt ja so diese Annahme, man wird nur gezielt überwacht. Also nur wenn man unter Verdacht gerät, wird man überwacht. Und was sozusagen die Netzaktivisten immer schon auch gesagt haben, ist halt so dieses, nee das stimmt gar nicht so, sondern das Gefährliche daran ist, dass alle immer überwacht werden, dass das vollautomatisiert abgeschnorchelt wird quasi und dann auch ausgewertet wird. Und das wurde ja durch Snowden dann tatsächlich irgendwie bestätigt. Da würde mich jetzt interessieren, ist es einfacher geworden, Verstößlung an den Mann, an die Frau zu bringen? Und benutzt sie jetzt auch anderes Zeug als vorher? Also hat sich technisch für euch und auch für die Allgemeinheit was geändert?
Also ich finde es auf jeden Fall einfacher, doch klar. Also ich hatte vorher so einen fest installierten Textbaustein, den ich zehn Jahre lang benutzt habe, wenn Leute versucht haben, mir Google-Mails zu schicken, wo ich immer, warum ist aber doof und so und dann kamen immer Zeug, ja aber geht nicht anders und ist so bequem. Und der war nicht mehr nötig. Also der war einfach nicht mehr nötig. Der kam, das kam nicht mehr, sondern höchstens so ein tut mir leid, ich hab's noch nicht geschafft davon wegzukommen, aber das hat sich ganz deutlich geändert und ich hab auch erheblich mehr Leuten dann Verschlüsselungen erklärt, die das auch von sich aus haben wollten. Und das ist bis jetzt so geblieben.
Ja, ich glaube, das hat sich auch so ein bisschen gesättigt. Also unmittelbar danach waren natürlich viel mehr Leute sensibler. Dann kam die ganze Story mit Glenn Greenwald hatte gar kein Open-PGP, keine E-Mail-Verschlüsselung und der Snowden wollte ihm ein halbes Jahr lang How-To's schicken, also Anleitungen, wie er das jetzt endlich installiert, damit er ihm die ganzen Dokumente zugeben, zu kommen lassen kann. Und das hat bei manchen Journalisten und so Leuten, die sich nicht originär als Nerds fühlen und den ganzen Tag mit Verschlüsselungen beschäftigen, schon dazu geführt, sich das endlich mal anzugucken. Bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt, glaube ich, aber auch alle Leute, die vorher so gesagt haben.
Journalisten sind aber auch die härtesten so dabei gewesen, ja. Na, am widerständigsten, irgendwas an ihrem Verhalten zu ändern. Also die waren schon so die, wo du sagst, ey, pass mal auf, es geht hier nicht nur um dich, es geht um deinen Quellenschutz. Und gerade wenn du mit Leuten arbeitest, die in riskanten Situationen sind, wo du auch echt so einen moralischen Hammer ab und zu mal rausholen musst. Und trotzdem sind sie sehr träge in der Veränderung.
Ja, ich glaube, alle Leute, die sich das schon immer mal vorgenommen haben, von denen haben es die meisten dann geschafft und sich mal damit beschäftigt. Es gibt aber immer noch leider viele Leute, die sagen, ja, ist halt so, ist mir zu aufwendig, kann ich nichts dagegen machen, was schade ist. Denn gerade nach dem Snowden Fallout haben wir eben auch Umfragen, die ganz klar belegen, ja, Leute nutzen Kommunikation anders und ändern ihr Verhalten, der Chilling-Effekt, die Auswirkung von Überwachung, dass man eben nicht mehr zu einer bestimmten Demo geht, irgendwas bestimmt, das jetzt nicht mehr online postet, weil man eben die Schere im Kopf hat, das wird ja eh alles überwacht, vielleicht könnte das irgendwann mal gegen mich verwendet werden. Und das ist ja der eigentliche Schaden an der Demokratie, weswegen wir gegen die Überwachung kämpfen.
Ich denke, es gab eigentlich zwei Effekte. Es gab einmal den, dass viele Menschen aufgestanden sind und gesagt haben, dagegen möchte ich mich schützen, was kann ich dagegen tun? Natürlich auch viel dann beim Chaos Computer Club und bei Mitgliedern des Chaos Computer Clubs und bei den Nerds natürlich nachgefragt haben und gleichzeitig natürlich damit konfrontiert waren, dass da die Usability noch so ein bisschen niedrig ist. Andererseits sie aber gemerkt haben, okay, irgendwie jeden Tag lese ich in der Zeitung, dass irgendetwas, was sicherer oder sonst wie geglaubt wurde, wieder aufgemacht wurde und ihnen auch so ein bisschen klar wurde, okay, wer kann mir denn jetzt eigentlich noch garantieren, dass irgendetwas, was mir hier irgendjemand andreht, wirklich sicher ist. Und wenn man dann so die ernsthafte Frage bekommen hat und wenn man dann mal ehrlich darauf antworten musste, dann hat man die Leute vielleicht häufig auch wieder so ein bisschen auf so einen Boden der Tatsachen auf so eine Resignation zurückgeholt, dass sie jetzt gesagt haben, ich will mich schützen, aber wenn selbst irgendwie hier so ein Security-Experte mir nicht wirklich sagen kann, ist das denn wirklich sicher, dann musst du erst mal ein Gespräch darüber anfangen, so na ja, was ist das Bedrohungsszenario, dem du dich ausgesetzt fühlst, um zu sagen, dass es sicher ist. Also ist deine Angst ein Massenüberwachungsgeheimdienst, dann ist das hier ein sehr gutes Mittel, dich zu schützen. Möchtest du irgendwie im Menschenhandel irgendwie einsteigen, dann ist das vielleicht eine Methode, auf die du dich nicht unbedingt verlassen solltest.
Fürs Protokoll, wir empfehlen das nicht, in den Menschenhandel einzusteigen.
Nein, das sowieso nicht, aber wenn, dann muss man sich ja schützen. Fluchthilfe und so. Aber wenn du, das heißt, wenn du, also diese Multidimensionalität der Sicherheit und dass es eben doch etwas komplizierter ist und dass einem ja doch irgendwie nichts passiert ist, das waren so zwei gegenläufige Effekte, die am Ende, glaube ich, darin gemündet haben, dass Produkte, die Sicherheit versprochen haben, und zwar Produkte im Sinne von marktbeworbene Produkte von Unternehmen, die Sicherheit versprochen haben, glaube ich, im Moment zu den größten Profiteuren gehört haben.
Aber ist das gut oder schlecht? Also weil die, es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass die, also die Lösungen, die damals empfohlen wurden, also E-Mail-Verschlüsselung zum Beispiel, die sind ja heute immer noch, ich sage das böse Wort, unbenutzbar. Natürlich geht es, wenn man irgendwie will, aber es ist nicht so, dass man es irgendjemand zumuten will, wenn es nicht unbedingt sein muss. Ich habe gerade neulich wieder viel Spaß mit verschlüsselten E-Mails gehabt. Und an die Stelle sind ja so, es gibt ja so zwei Bewegungen. Das eine ist jetzt so, dass konkret Produkte entstehen. Also es gibt so einen Markt für Messenger, es gibt immer noch WhatsApp. Selbst die verschlüsseln jetzt irgendwie, man weiß es nicht genau, ob es funktioniert oder so, aber es geht halt. Und es gibt dann konkret Messenger, die sagen, wir sind jetzt sicher. Und das andere ist, dass auch selbst große Firmen sagen, so wir schreiben jetzt Datenschutz mal groß. Also Google hat zum Beispiel, das war, glaube ich, die erste große Sache irgendwann gesagt, wir verschlüsseln den Datenverkehr, der intern bei unseren Sachen läuft. Ist das sozusagen, du hast es gerade Profiteure gesagt, heißt das, die machen damit nur Geld, das funktioniert eigentlich gar nicht? Oder ist das schon auch eine positive Entwicklung?
Also das ist natürlich, also wann immer Sicherheit erhöht wird, ist es eine positive Entwicklung. Und wann immer Massen abhören, erschwert wird, ist es eine gute Sache. Und das selbst...
Was passiert auch durch diese Dinge?
Ja, ich denke, da sind eine ganze Menge Sachen getan worden, die einen Effekt haben. Man könnte jetzt im Nachhinein noch in philosophischer Runde darüber streiten, ob da lange Versäumnisse überhaupt aufgeholt wurden. Aber wenn man einfach den Status davor mit dem Status danach vergleicht, denke ich, ist eine Menge passiert, die heute für eine höhere Sicherheit sorgt. Dass die Triebfeder dahinter unter Umständen Marketingerwägungen sind, ist natürlich dann ein Vaterbeigeschmack für Idealisten. Aber wenn wir einfach nur darauf blicken, was sich technisch geändert hat, dann haben, glaube ich, den größten Schutz, also wenn man quasi Erhöhung des Schutzniveaus mal Menschen, für die es zutrifft, nimmt, dann sind gerade die Maßnahmen natürlich der großen Unternehmen diejenigen, die signifikante Verbesserungen für viele Teile der Welt geschaffen haben.
Okay, also nochmal, um es zusammenzufassen, es ist schwierig, sich komplett sicher zu machen, aber es ist relativ einfach geworden, mittlerweile sich gegen diese Massenüberwachung zu wärtsetzen, dass man automatisch quasi von einem alles mitgeschöpft wird. Anne, du hast ja erzählt, du hast zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt für eine NGO gearbeitet, die sich damit beschäftigt, anderen Leuten zu erklären, wie sie sicher kommunizieren können. Wenn du den Job immer noch machen würdest, wäre das mittlerweile einfacher, weil es da neue Produkte gibt?
Nein, weil die Produkte, wenn man das so nennen will, die wir empfohlen haben, die haben wir jetzt nicht so alle fünf Minuten gewechselt, sondern das waren Sachen, die relativ lange erprobt waren, die sozusagen gut abgehangen waren und relativ gut durchgecheckt waren. Und da hat sich nicht so viel daran geändert, außer dass TrueCrypt weggebrochen ist.
Das ist ein System zur Verschlüsselung von Festplatten gewesen.
Insofern ist das im Wesentlichen das Gleiche geblieben, glaube ich. Das letzte Dreivierteljahr habe ich jetzt nicht mehr so eng verfolgt. Und das war im Grunde auch okay. Also wir haben letztlich, nachdem wir so den ersten Schock so alles kaputt, man weiß nicht mehr genau, was geht und was nicht geht, im Grunde an dem, was wir den Leuten zu empfohlen haben, nicht so viel geändert, weil wir immer schon gesagt haben, perfekte digitale Sicherheit gibt es nicht. Wenn du bei irgendwas wirklich sicher sein willst, dass nicht mitgehört wird, dann solltest du einfach überhaupt nicht digital kommunizieren. Und ansonsten ist der Ansatz tatsächlich zu sagen, jedes bisschen mehr an digitaler Sicherheit ist erst mal ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Und es geht im Wesentlichen darum, natürlich auch gerade wenn du auf die Massenüberwachung guckst, zu sagen, es muss da eine kritische Masse von Leuten her, die das benutzen, weil es das der Gegenseite einfach auch schwieriger macht, das Zeug einfach so einzusammeln. Je mehr niedrige Level von Schutzmaßnahmen benutzen, desto mehr werden dann auch die geschützt, die den Schutz wirklich brauchen. Und wir haben vor allen Dingen, also Tactical Tech arbeitet vor allen Dingen, mit Menschenrechtsorganisationen, mit Aktivisten, Journalistinnen im außereuropäischen Raum, die teilweise in sehr repressiven politischen Situationen sich befinden und da einfach auch wirklich und tatsächlich auch mit fiesen Gefahren natürlich konfrontiert sind. Also wenn wir jetzt uns angucken, Finn Fischer oder so, dagegen nützt TextSecure dann auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
Das ist aber der Finn Fischer, musst du nochmal ganz kurz?
Finn Fischer ist ein Trojaner, da können die anderen beiden glaube ich deutlich mehr nochmal dazu sagen, aber der, der von Regimes unter anderem insbesondere zur Verfolgung von Oppositionellen benutzt wird und auch tatsächlich ganz gezielt gegen bestimmte Personen eingesetzt wird und es ist auch nachgewiesen, dass Leute deswegen dann gefoltert wurden und im Knast gelandet sind. Und das ist halt diese klassische Geschichte irgendwie, du weißt nicht, ob deine Webcam gesteuert wird, es werden deine Tastaturbewegungen aufgezeichnet. Das heißt, auch wenn du ein tolles Verschlüsselungsprogramm hast, in dem Moment, wo du das Passwort eingibst und das wird aber aufgezeichnet, dann nützt dir die Verschlüsselung natürlich nichts. Das heißt, dagegen kann man sich nur schlecht schützen, aber in der Annahme, dass jetzt nicht alle Leute mit einem Finn Fischer Trojaner verfolgt werden, hilft es natürlich ganz vielen Leuten trotzdem.
Okay, wir werden gleich noch mal genauer drüber reden, was so einzelne Dinge sind, die man da benutzen kann, die ihr vielleicht selber benutzt und auch über die politische Aufarbeitung dieses ganzen Stonenskandals reden. Aber vorher gibt es die Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr, dann sind wir gleich wieder da im Chaosradio.
Morgennacht und Samstagnacht überträgt Fritz live und im Radio. Das Berlin Festival mit mehr als 80 Live-Acts und DJ-Sets. Das Berlin-Festival. Auf dem Gelände der Arena Berlin. Und Fritz überträgt euch die besten DJ-Sets. Morgen Nacht und Samstag Nacht.
Mehr dazu auf fritz.de.
Das Berlin-Festival.
FIFA-Präsident Blatter hat zum ersten Mal etwas zum Korruptionsskandal gesagt. Zu Beginn des FIFA-Kongresses in Zürich sagte er, dass er sich nichts vorzuwerfen hat. Den Korruptionsskandal bezeichnete er als eine Schande für den Fußball. Der Europäische Fußballverband UEFA hatte Blatter heute aufgefordert, zurückzutreten. Morgen stellt sich Blatter beim FIFA-Kongress für eine fünfte Amtszeit zur Wahl. Die UEFA hat angekündigt, ihn nicht zu wählen. Brandenburgs Landesregierung ist dafür, dass schwule und lesbische Paare auch in Deutschland heiraten dürfen. Sie will eine Bundesratsinitiative zur Gleichstellung mit der Ehe unterstützen. Auch mehrere andere Bundesländer sind dafür. Vor zwei Jahren gab es im Bundesrat schon mal eine Mehrheit für einen ähnlichen Gesetzentwurf. Der war dann aber bis zum Ende der Legislaturperiode nicht mehr im Bundestag beraten worden. Verfassungsschützer fordern, dass junge Leute besser über Propaganda von Extremisten aufgeklärt werden. Rechtsextremisten und Terrorgruppen wie der Islamische Staat nutzen immer stärker YouTube und Facebook, um Jugendliche anzuwerben. Über dieses Problem wurde heute bei einer Tagung der ausdeutschen Verfassungsschutzbehörden in Potsdam gesprochen. Experten warnten davor, dass Extremisten über das Internet in Sekundenschnelle Jugendliche überall auf der Welt erreichen und beeinflussen können. Das Relegationsspiel zwischen dem Hamburger SV und dem Karlsruher SC ist gerade 1 zu 1 ausgegangen. Das Rückspiel ist nächsten Montag in Karlsruhe. Alba Berlin hat im Halbfinalduell der Basketball-Bundesliga gegen Bayern München verloren. 73 zu 85 ist es ausgegangen. Damit steht es in der Best of 5 Serie 1 zu 1. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, wir haben in Berlin-Schwandau 11 und in Friedrichshain 12 Grad brennt es laut 10 Brandenburg an der Havel und Wiesenburg 11 Grad, Forst noch 16. In der Nacht kann es immer mal wieder Regen geben, bei 10 bis 4 Grad. Morgen wird es dann ähnlich wie es heute war, es gibt Sonne, Wolken und Regen bei 18 bis 22 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin 100, Stadtring Richtung Wedding zwischen Kurfürstendamm und Dreieck Funkturm, da sind zwei Spuren gesperrt. Tiergartenstraße des 17. Juni zwischen Brandenburger Tor und die Zerkrabinstraße, Vollsperrung bis zum 11. Juni, ebenfalls komplett gesperrt ist die Ebertstraße am Brandenburger Tor. Grund ist das UEFA Champions League Festival. Nach Brandenburg A10 westlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck Werder, zwischen Leest und Havelbrück liegt ein totes Tier auf der Fahrbahn. Unter 13 Berlin Dresden zwischen Teubitz und Baruqmarck in beiden Richtungen, Achtung, da sind Menschen auf der Autobahn unterwegs.
Dann hört doch mal den Fritz Zauber mit Schöckern. Immer Dienstags ab 20 Uhr und im Radio.
Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de Musikstreams. Der Blumen ist heute das Chaosradio, das Chaosradio auf Fritz und es geht heute um zwei Jahresnoten und was davon übrig blieb und was wir so erlebt haben. Wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde schon geklärt, wie das damals so war und wie sich die Technik daraufhin so ein bisschen verändert hat und was die krassesten Dinge waren, die da an das Tageslicht kamen, wie wir überwacht werden und wir, das sind in diesem Fall die Gäste, Linus Neumann vom Kars Computer Club.
Hallo, schönen guten Abend.
Andre Meister von Netzpolitik Org.
Hallo Internet.
Und Anne Roth, ich sag jetzt mal aus dem Bundestag, dass das genauer bedeutet, das klären wir noch. Hallo. So, wir haben jetzt gerade schon mal über die Technik geredet und wie die sich verändert hat, dass es sozusagen jetzt Vermehrtangebote gibt, die ein sicheres Kommunizieren im Internet ermöglicht, ohne es vollständig unangreifbar zu machen, aber zumindest so Massenüberwachung irgendwie verhindern kann. Was ich euch fragen wollen würde, ist so, einerseits, es gibt ja genau diese Diskussion um so sichere Messenger. Also man hat auf dem Smartphone so ein Textding, wo man auch Bilder verstehen kann und so was. Da gibt es so ein paar Angebote. Könnt ihr da irgendwas empfehlen? Nutzt ihr da selber irgendwas von oder ist das eigentlich so was, wo ihr sagt, nein, da wollen wir nie was zu sagen, weil eigentlich ist alles schlimm?
Genau.
Wie? Wie, noch mal?
Also der Chaos Computer Club empfiehlt ja grundsätzlich nichts. Man könnte sagen, wir raten von der Nutzung von Computern ab.
Aber ich meine, das wird doch zum Problem, oder nicht? Weil wenn man den Leuten sozusagen, wenn man sich nicht traut, den Leuten was zu sagen, dann gehen die halt zu WhatsApp oder Facebook.
Mir ist vor allem diese Unterscheidung wichtig, zu sagen, die Snowden-Problematik ist eine Problematik der Massenüberwachung. Und was wir jetzt tun müssen, ist erstmal die Massenüberwachung loswerden. Wenn du davon ausgehst, dass du...
Wenn wir das dann erledigt haben.
Step by step machen wir das jetzt, dann werden wir fünf Jahre ausplanen.
Aber das ist schon noch eine Politiker-Antwort, die du jetzt gibst, ne? Ich frage dich nach einer konkreten Empfehlung. Du sagst, wir müssen erstmal das globale Problem klären.
Ja, aber jetzt gehst du mit mir auch um wie so ein Radiomoderator mit einem Politiker und unterbrichst mich. Also, es gibt in der ersten Stufe, denke ich mal, eine Menge Methoden, die adäquat sind, um sich gegen Massenüberwachung zu schützen. Und es gibt dann für Fluchthelfer und andere Freiheitskämpfer nochmal Methoden, um sich besser gegen auch gezielte Angriffe zu schützen. Und ich denke, das muss man immer auch unterscheiden, Massenüberwachung, gezielte Angriffe. Ersteres geht relativ einfach, da kann man dann auch viel empfehlen, was auch alles wahrscheinlich relativ nützlich ist. Diese gezielten Angriffe muss man dann aber auch immer bei jeder Empfehlung ausfaktorisieren, die der Andre dann jetzt geben wird.
Das ist wirklich wie in der Politik hier, mal gucken, was der Andre sagt.
Na, ich würde tatsächlich ein paar Sachen empfehlen. Ich bin zwar auch im Chaos Computer Club, aber nicht als Sprecherrolle. Deswegen darf ich das auch tun, ohne gleich auf den Deckel zu bekommen. Und zwar ist es gar nicht mehr so schwer, einfach einen Browser zum Anonymisieren im Web zu nutzen. Tor Browser kann sich jeder einfach runterladen und dann wissen eben weder der Nachbarn im WLAN noch der Arbeitgeber oder der WG-Mitbewohner oder der Chef, was man gerade so im Internet an-serve und auch nicht mehr der eigene Provider. Das schafft sogar der Monox-Street. Einfach torproject.org. Und dann auch die Messenger auf dem Telefon sind um Längen besser als eine unverschlüsselte SMS, die halt wirklich bei Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben wir wieder, wo jede einzelne Nachricht wirklich eine konkrete Spur hinterlässt. Bei den Messagern von den Smartphones tun das die wenigsten derzeit zumindest für lokale Cops oder Behörden in Deutschland oder auch einen Arbeitgeber oder ein eifersüchtiger Ex-Partner. Eine konkrete Empfehlung muss ich jetzt nicht geben. Ich würde natürlich sagen, die, die frei und offen sind. Da gibt es ja aber mittlerweile eine Handvoll seriöser, langlebiger Instant-Messenger, die sich so auf den Smartphone halten. Und ansonsten möchte ich natürlich trotzdem empfehlen.
Wenn du jetzt schon keinen Namen sagst, dann ist wieder die nächste Frage so, wo gehe ich denn hin? Also irgendjemand muss doch mal was sagen können.
Ich.
Okay, dann fragen wir gleich Anne.
Ich bin ja nicht im CCC. Ich darf Sachen empfehlen. Und ich finde das auch total gut, weil vor mir stehen echt häufig Leute, die sagen, ey, ich habe keine Ahnung, es gibt so viel Zeug, was soll ich denn jetzt benutzen, was mache ich denn jetzt? Und der Politiker-Teil der Antwort ist, es kommt so ein bisschen darauf an, wen man vor sich hat. Ja, also wenn das irgendwelche, wie gesagt, Leute sind, die sich für Landrechte in Brasilien einsetzen oder in Indien, das ist einfach eine andere Bedrohungslage als irgendwelche Lehrer in Berlin oder so.
Genau, also nur um das jetzt noch mal zu sagen, ich würde jetzt natürlich gerne sozusagen über den, Anführungszeichen, normalen User reden, also jemand, der keiner konkreten...
Also der normale User oder die normale Userin hier in Berlin, ohne besondere politische Bedrohung oder Drogenhändler oder was weiß ich, da gibt es schon eine ganze Menge Sachen so. Und ich würde auch Messenger empfehlen. Ich würde zum Beispiel sagen, Leute, die Android-Telefone benutzen, die sollten Text Secure benutzen. Das kostet nichts, das ist Open Source, da ist bisher noch nichts gegen gesagt worden oder irgendwas gefunden worden, was Sachen sagen würde, das ist kompromittiert. Dazu gibt es mittlerweile das Gegenstück für iPhones auch, das heißt Signal. Das ist schon mal ein super Anfang. Oder beim Browsen beispielsweise gibt es eine Reihe von Add-ons, die so für das grobe an Massenüberwachung unheimlich hilfreich sind. Eins davon heißt HTTPS Everywhere, das verschlüsselt die Transportwege. Das heißt, hilft so ein bisschen dabei, dass zwischen mir und der Webseite, die ich ansurfe, also dem Server, den ich da kontaktiere auf der anderen Seite, dazwischen nicht ganz so viele Leute mitlesen können und eine ganze Reihe von Add-ons, die Tracking zumindest behindern teilweise. Da würde ich sagen, AdBlock Plus ist eine ganz gute Empfehlung oder NoScript zum Beispiel, um das Ausführen von Skripten so ein bisschen besser unter Kontrolle zu haben. Da gibt es, also da könnte man jetzt noch einiges mehr zusagen. Ich könnte auch eine super Webseite von Tactical Tech empfehlen, wo ganz viel davon drauf steht, weil wir eben dort tatsächlich uns auch zur Aufgabe gemacht haben, Leuten ganz konkret zu helfen und zu sagen, wenn dein Problem ist, du willst E-Mail-Verschlüsse, dann geht es hier lang. Wenn dein Problem ist, du willst diese ganzen Werbetracking-Sachen mal so ein bisschen verstehen und in den Griff kriegen, dann geht es da lang. Messenger gibt es hier und so weiter und noch eine ganze Reihe von anderen Sachen. Und viel davon ist tatsächlich relativ einfach auch zu installieren. Wenn man sich nicht vornimmt zu denken, ich muss das jetzt alles auf einmal verstehen und ich muss das alles auf einmal machen, sondern sagen, hier, ich nehme mir dafür immer so ein bisschen Zeit und am Wochenende eine halbe Stunde und installiere mir einen so einen Add-on so und damit habe ich mich nicht komplett geschützt, aber damit bin ich einen Schritt weiter und das finde ich eigentlich eine ganz gute Hausnummer so für den Wald- und Wiesengebrauch hierzulande.
Das will ich mal gerade sagen, da gibt es fast schon eine Art, gibt es schon eine Worte Paradigmenwechsel. Gerade in der Diskussion mit Leuten, die sich wirklich heftig mit Sicherheit beschäftigen, ist immer so, entweder du machst es richtig perfekt oder du machst es halt gar nicht, dann kannst du auch gleich ganz das und das hat sich so ein bisschen jetzt anscheinend gewechselt in den letzten zwei Jahren auch zu, okay, es gibt Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Das ist gut, wenn du die erstmal macht.
Wir haben ja vor allem auch gesehen, wo uns das geführt hat. Also ich meine, über 20 Jahre hat man da irgendwie gestanden und gesagt, ja, nein, du musst jetzt hier PGP machen und du musst den gesamten Fingerprint und keinen Key-Server und hast ja alles nicht gesehen. Und du hast irgendwie die meisten Nutzer nicht verloren, sondern halt nie bekommen. Und genauso dieses reine Leere-Paradigma hat eben auch zu dem Disconnect geführt, der jetzt mit so Usability-Initiativen, wie gesagt hauptsächlich von Start-ups oder anderen Unternehmen, aber natürlich auch viel aus der Community, wieder geschlossen wird. Also es war lange Zeit völlig normal, dass man sagt, die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung muss selbstverständlich von dem Produkt getrennt sein, sie muss davon unabhängig sein, sonst ist dem Produkt nicht zu trauen. Wunderbar hat dazu geführt, dass wir allein ein paar Jahre auf iPhones oder so einfach keine ernst zu nehmenden, Ende-zu-Ende-verschlüsselenden Tools hatten. Gab's einfach gar nicht. Und dann kam Threema auf, das wurde dann ein Hype, die haben es noch geschafft durch dieses Codescan, so eine körperlich nahe Komponente zu geben.
Also das ist eine kurze Erklärung, das ist ein Messenger, wo man den Kontakt zwar auch übers Netz herstellen kann, aber wo der wirklich sichere Kontakt erst dann hergestellt ist, wenn man den anderen getroffen hat und nicht gegenseitig ein QR-Code vom Smartphone abgescannt hat.
Genau, weil man dann wirklich verifiziert hat, dass man mit einem Schlüssel verschlüsselt, den der andere auch hat und nicht jemand dazwischen ist, der einen anderen Schlüssel unterjubelt.
Das ist tatsächlich ein ganz gutes Beispiel, weil das gibt es bei E-Mail-Verschüsselungen auch. Da war es aber immer ein Problem bis zu erklären und die haben es irgendwie geschafft, das Problem total zu umgehen. Einfach nur zu sagen, ja macht das einfach so, das ist dann super.
Ja, anders hat man es den Leuten auch nicht beibringen können. So viel Zeit hatten die meistens nicht.
Okay, das ist sozusagen der technische Teil und es gibt ja auch in der Diskussion darum, wie mit den Snowden, die es umgegangen wird, also tatsächlich zwei Lager und manche Leute sagen beides. Nämlich, wir müssen das durch die Technik klären, also wir als Betroffene durch die Überwachung, wir werden uns, der andere sagt, naja, man müsste das eigentlich politisch klären. Also weil diese Überwachung wird ja von irgendjemandem in Auftrag gegeben, irgendjemand führt die durch und da könnte man ja vielleicht mal was ändern. Und dann kommen wir zu dem Punkt, wo vor allen Dingen hier Andre und Anne auch ganz viel arbeiten, nämlich zum NSAUA, dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag. Oder? Ist doch korrekt. Stimmt, parlamentares Kontrollgebung ist auch da, Steffan. Bevor wir aber dazu kommen, also was bei uns hier ganz konkret vor der Haustür passiert ist, wie reagieren, wie ist denn so generell die politische Reaktion in anderen Ländern auf Snowden? Also wir werden jetzt gleich sozusagen den ganzen Rest der Sendung wahrscheinlich über uns reden, aber vorher hätte ich gerne noch so einen kurzen Überblick. Spielt das in anderen Ländern eine Rolle, wenn ja, wie wird darauf reagiert?
Also natürlich wurden die Enthüllungen weltweit wahrgenommen, in verschiedenen Staaten unterschiedlich, aber auch in den verschiedensten Gremien auf den verschiedensten Leveln. Also wir haben jetzt UN-Resolutionen von Brasilien und Deutschland, einen neuen UN-Sonderbericht erstattern zum Thema Datenschutz. Wir hatten im Europäischen Parlament den Liebeausschuss, den es schon immer gibt, der hat einen Sonderbericht zu dem Thema gemacht, auch mit Anhörungen von Edward Snowden und ein paar anderen Experten aus unserem Umfeld. Wir haben Debatten in Brasilien und anderen Staaten, ob sie nicht auch so eine Art Untersuchung machen, ob sie ihre Infrastruktur unabhängiger von den USA und den Five Eyes-Ländern machen. Und wir haben natürlich in Deutschland den Untersuchungsausschuss im Deutschen Bundestag, der weltweit noch so ein bisschen einmalig ist, weil der wirklich von Grund auf versucht, den Enthüllungen auf den Grund zu gehen mit Akten und Vorladungen von Zeugen, was es so noch in keinem anderen Parlament gegeben hat. Vielleicht bekommen wir das demnächst in Österreich, wo jetzt auch Politiker gerade rumrennen, wo auch die Involviertheit des Deutschen BND mit der NSA zusammen und eine Überwachung von Österreich von diesen beiden Stellen auch dazu führt, dass Leute auch dort einen Untersuchungsausschuss gründen würden. Also weltweit ist da die Aufmerksamkeit ein bisschen unterschiedlich. Alle schielen auch so ein bisschen auf Deutschland, das klassische Datenschutzland oder so. Aber durchaus ist auch in einigen anderen Staaten was passiert. Auch in den USA selbst sind unsere Freunde, die immer die Verschwörungstheoretiker waren, jetzt ernster genommen von bestimmten Politikern. Das passiert auf der ganzen Welt.
Jetzt ist, wenn man das in den USA betrachtet, ganz spannend, Snowden selbst, wenn man den Interviews zuhört, da geht es vor allen Dingen darum, dass eigene Bürger nicht belauscht werden. Das klingt manchmal so, solange die NSA und die ganzen anderen Sachen so irgendjemand irgendwo belauschen, ist das schon ganz okay. Aber wehe ist es in den US-Bürgern dran? Das ist so das, was bei mir manchmal ankommt.
Ist das korrekt, oder? Einen Halbsatz noch auf der ganzen Welt. Ich muss schon sagen, es ist die westliche, nördliche Welt, auf der sich so ein bisschen was tut. Und der ganze doch noch wesentlich größere Rest der Welt, finde ich, ist noch mal ein bisschen ein anderes Kapitel. Okay, Brasilien. Ein bisschen Pakistan, ein bisschen Indien soweit. Ich weiß aber nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Und dann gibt es einfach noch ganz, ganz viele Länder. Und wir haben so in dem Jahr nach Snowden, als ich noch bei Tactical Tech, als ich noch mit vielen Leuten auch aus eben, wie gesagt, aus dem Olympischen Raum auch darüber geredet habe und immer wieder auch gefragt habe, was bedeutet denn das für euch? Was hat denn das für Auswirkungen, auch für eure praktische Arbeit? Kam in der Regel die Reaktion, ja, ist irgendwie theoretisch interessant, aber unsere Bedrohungslage ist echt eine ganz andere. Wie gesagt, wir haben hier mit Fynn Fischer zu tun. Und da ist das mit Snowden und so irgendwie ganz interessant, aber einfach gerade nicht unser Problem. Das ist jetzt auch ein bisschen zugespitzt, aber deswegen wäre ich mit dieser Formulierung auf der ganzen Welt so ein bisschen vorsichtig. Ich glaube, da muss man noch mal so ein bisschen gucken, wer das dann ist.
Also das heißt, um sich gegen Maskenüberwachung zu werden, muss es einem erst mal gut genug gehen?
Zumindest ist das bei den Leuten, die sich überhaupt mit dieser Sorte Bedrohungslage beschäftigen und die ein Verständnis dafür haben und vielleicht auch das Wissen haben und die Verbindungen haben und in dieser Form vernetzt sind. Die haben, soweit ich das beurteilen kann und ich habe auch nur einen ganz kleinen Einblick, einfach erst mal was anderes zu tun gehabt, würde ich sagen. Nichtsdestotrotz ist auch da überall das Problem, dass sie Leute gebraucht und gesucht haben, die Workshops geben können für zum Beispiel Journalistinnen und Journalisten oder Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten, wo Sachen jenseits von Finn Fischer auch eine Rolle gespielt haben, nämlich mehr Verschlüsselung, wie authentifiziere ich überhaupt, dass mein Gegenüber mein Gegenüber ist, wie bringe ich irgendwelche Datenbeweise über die Grenze außerhalb der Reichweite von unserer jeweiligen Sicherheitsbehörde und so weiter. Und deswegen würde ich nicht sagen, es muss einem gut genug gehen, weil es ist schwer zu bewerten, aber es ist einfach ein bisschen unterschiedlich.
Ich würde das schon aufgreifen. Also es gibt auf der Welt neun von zehn Leuten, die was zu essen haben. Und es gibt halt einfach Milliarden Menschen, die haben ganz andere Sorgen den ganzen Tag. Also es gibt Flüchtlinge, Kriege. Tatsächlich muss man erst mal in die Situation kommen, soweit politische zu betätigen und Gedanken über Gemeinwohl, über eine lokale Gemeinschaft hinaus zu machen, das machen zu wollen. Und tatsächlich, wenn ich irgendwo in Vietnam oder Nicaragua politischer Aktivist bin, dann habe ich ganz andere Threat Level, unmittelbare Bedrohungen, was Anna ja auch schon gesagt hat in Pakistan, als jetzt irgendwie das Supergeheimdienst der USA, der sowieso alles bekommt. Also tatsächlich würde ich das schon ein bisschen relativieren, dass wir da hier eine Debatte führen, die wir tatsächlich ein bisschen in der westlichen Welt haben und uns grundsätzliche Gedanken über Demokratie und Zusammenleben auch mit dem Rest der Welt machen. Aber wir haben jetzt nicht den ganzen Tag, um über unser Leben zu kämpfen.
Und dann kommt noch mit dazu, dass wir wenigstens Datenschutzgesetze hier haben. Die hast du in ganz vielen Ländern einfach nicht, wo die Leute sagen, ihr beschwert euch jetzt, dass die sich nicht an eure Gesetze halten, aber wir haben die halt einfach gar nicht so. Wir sind einfach an einem ganz anderen Punkt der Problemlage. Und dann würde ich nochmal, ich weiß jetzt nicht, zu deiner Frage zu den USA und dass das nur die US-Bürger betrifft, ob wir dazu jetzt nochmal hinschwenken wollen. Das ist ein Unterton, ich finde, der verliert sich wieder so ein bisschen, aber der war eine Weile lang deutlich zu hören, wieso interessieren sich gerade dann auch die Grundrechteorganisationen in den USA. Die führen ihre Prozesse dann immer nur entlang dieser Frage, ob da jetzt die Rechte der US-Bürgerinnen und US-Bürger verletzt sind und was ist denn mit dem Rest der Welt. Das ist halt einfach die einzige Chance, die sie haben, um ihre Regierung anzugreifen. Das ist bei uns im Untersuchungsausschuss nicht wirklich anders. Wir überprüfen auch das Verhalten des BND entlang der BND-Gesetzgebung, die wir halt haben und die schützt zumindest aus Perspektive der Bundesregierung nur deutsche Bürgerinnen und Bürger oder, je nachdem, dass sozusagen Leute, die in Deutschland leben, wenn es gut läuft. Aber selbst daran halten sie sich nicht. Und da können wir sie zumindest darauf festklopfen, dass das andere politisch falsch ist, ist sozusagen dann der nächste Schritt.
Holy, da steht ja noch viel Arbeit bevor. Bevor wir tatsächlich zur politischen Dimension kommen, noch einen Anrufer, könnt auch gerne anrufen, 0331 77 97 21 20. Und zwar Nils, der nochmal was zu den persönlichen technischen Konsequenzen sieht. Hallo Nils. So, jetzt hast du ja gehört, dass Verschlüsselung eigentlich eine gute Sache ist. Und jetzt sagst du aber so, naja, so geil ist es dann doch nicht. Warum?
Warum? Also ich habe mal, als das mit Snowden angefangen hat, bin ich auch auf diesem Trepp, ah, man muss alles verschlüsseln. Und irgendwie sichere Messenger verwenden und PGP und was weiß ich nicht alles. Und inzwischen bin ich davon so ein bisschen abgekommen. Also wenn ich mir so meinen Webbrowser angucke, ich habe als vorhin HTTPS Everywhere erwähnt wurde, ist mir aufgefallen, oh, ist ja gar nicht mehr installiert. Deswegen läuft das in letzter Zeit so rund, das Webbrowsen, weil ich immer wieder Probleme hatte, dass Seiten irgendwie Inhalte halt dann nicht verschlüsselt ausgeliefert haben und dann die gar nicht mehr dargestellt wurden. Und also das ist ja bei NoScripten was weiß ich nicht ähnliches. Also man macht es zwar irgendwie sicherer, aber die Pein wird größer. Und bei den Messengern, da ist man dann auf Fremar gegangen und dann heißt es jetzt, naja, eigentlich müssten wir AttackSecure verwenden, seitdem es ja auch Signal gibt. Aber jetzt kriege ich die ganzen Leute ja nicht mehr von Fremar, also ohne weiter Respekt. Da müsste ich jetzt die ganze Überzeugungsarbeit nochmal leisten, abgesehen von den Leuten, die sagen, ja nee, ich habe WhatsApp und das brauche ich immer alle meine anderen Leute, die ich so kenne, haben WhatsApp. Und das hängt dann auch wieder so ein bisschen. Mal abgesehen von dieser ganzen Metadatengeschichte, die ja dann auch in der Totalüberwachung ja auch irgendwie nicht wegbekommt.
Also da muss man kurz erklären, Metadaten sozusagen nicht die Daten, die bei der Kommunikation direkt anfangen, also worüber ihr schreibt, sondern wer schreibt gerade mit wem, wohin.
Ja genau.
Die fallen halt auch bei verschlüsselter Kommunikation meistens an. Ja genau. Du hast quasi jetzt einfach resigniert und hast gesagt, mir egal, was man machen soll.
Ja genau. Also das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen, es ist halt mehr Pain als Gain, fühlt es sich so ein bisschen an, so nach der ganzen Zeit. Es ändert sich halt nichts und an sich kann die Änderung nur von politischer Seite kommen. Und sowas wie die Inhalte, dass halt Metadaten an sich ja interessanter sind als die Inhalte. Und ich höchstens Angst haben muss vor der Profilbildung, dass ich mal so in dieses Brazil-Ding reinkomme, dass ich irgendwie über ein falsches Profil, also dass halt quasi irgendwie Nachrichtendienste zwar alles einsammeln und dann der Algorithmus meint, ja, der ist böse, obwohl ich gar nicht böse bin, sondern irgendwie ein toller Fehler oder Ausreißer da drin. Der Meinung war, dass ich jetzt böse bin, habe ich irgendwie so als Privatperson, naja, das Trap-Model ist mir irgendwie nicht klar, wogegen ich mich einsperren soll.
Dagegen die Massüberwachung, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Linus, du wolltest das sagen?
Zwei Punkte. Ich denke, die Probleme, die du da jetzt festgestellt hast, sind erstmal keine, die wirklich mit den Tools, die du verwenden, direkt zu tun haben. Also wenn Webseiten Scheiße geschrieben sind, sodass sie, obwohl sie verschlüsselt aufgerufen werden, immer noch unverschlüsselte Inhalte einbinden, dann ist das ein schwerer handwerklicher Fehler auf Seite der Webseite. Und dein Tool zieht die notwendigen Konsequenzen, um dich entsprechend zu schützen. Trotzdem hast du natürlich recht, dass da für dich einfach die User Experience leidet. Andererseits denke ich, ist es sehr wichtig, dass wir eben auch dieses Zeichen einfach mal setzen. Denn wie gesagt, dadurch, dass sich nie jemand beschwert hat, sind wir überhaupt in diese Situation geraten, in der wir jetzt als Gesellschaft sind. Und das ist der zweite Punkt, den ich anbringen wollte. Für dich persönlich geht es da um nichts. Dass du in dieser Brasil-Fliegensituation landest und irgendwie persönlich dann getargetet wirst, da müsstest du schon Anne Roth sein, der das alles schon passiert ist.
Ich möchte ganz kurz, Brasil ist ein Film, in dem es genau darum geht, dass jemand fälschlicherweise verdächtigt wird, nur um es mal geklärt zu haben, damit es nicht als Kotwort hier ist.
Das heißt, um als ein unverschuldet Opfer oder Ziel dieser Überwachung zu werden, musst du schon so viel Pech haben wie Anne, die das über viele Jahre am eigenen Leib erlebt hat. Es geht aber vielmehr bei dieser Massenüberwachung darum, dass wir einen Wert in unserer Gesellschaft verteidigen. Es geht nicht darum, dich persönlich zu schützen, sondern es geht darum, auf eine Veränderung in unserer Gesellschaft hinzuwirken, von der wir alle und unsere Demokratie profitieren werden. Und der individuelle Schutz, denke ich, sollte davor auch im Hintergrund stehen.
Ja, da würde ich aber auch gerne noch einhaken. Zum Schutz der Demokratie ist aber Krypto eher Abwehr. Ich möchte mich jetzt den allumfassenden Netz entziehen. Deswegen finde ich die politische Perspektive, Marcus, du hast das vorhin angesprochen, zwischen Technik und Politik, finde ich die politische Perspektive größer. Denn eigentlich sollten wir uns gar nicht schützen müssen. Sondern da draußen gibt es wildgewordene Geheimdienste, die fucking alles überwachen. Und das sollten wir schläufig beenden und unsere Demokratie zurückerobern und uns nicht verstecken müssen.
Also das heißt, du würdest Nils sagen, du darfst ruhig resignieren, weil das ist...
Nee, das nicht. Der sonst einhalte TBS-Embüwer wieder installieren, das geht auch gut.
Anne noch?
Und mein Take ist noch ein anderer, weil ich finde so dieses leicht moralisierende hier, du musst jetzt aber mitmachen beim Weltretten, ist natürlich irgendwie schon in Ordnung, aber das hilft mir natürlich nicht dabei. Ich sage, das funktioniert alles nicht richtig und früher war es viel schöner. Ich würde den wie immer hinkenden Vergleich mal ranholen, zum Beispiel mit Ernährung. Also wenn du total gerne Grillhähnchen isst und die super lecker findest und dir dabei noch nie Gedanken darüber gemacht hast, dass das halt einfach Käfighühner sind und voller Antibiotika, weil sie halt einfach voll lecker sind, dann ist es relativ schwierig, dich dazu zu kriegen, jetzt Veganer zu werden. Und dazwischen gibt es aber 25 verschiedene Stufen von Sachen und alle Leute entscheiden sich unterschiedlich, weil sie entweder das mit den Hähnchen in den Käfigen doof finden oder das mit den Antibiotika doof finden oder irgendwann die ganzen Geschmacksverstärker nicht mehr mögen und dann sich ein bisschen gesünder ernähren. Und so ähnlich ist es mit der Verschlüsselung letztlich auch, dass du einfach überlegen musst, klar ist immer eine Abwägung Bequemlichkeit versus Sicherheit. Das sind sozusagen die beiden Enden, dieser Skala, von der wir da sitzen. Und es gibt aber nicht nur diese beiden Enden, sondern es gibt dazwischen ganz viel. Und das müssen einfach alle für sich entscheiden, wie viel sie davon haben wollen. Und die Leute, die dann zum Schluss die gesunden veganen Körner tatsächlich lecker finden, das ist natürlich super, aber das geht halt einfach nicht allen Leuten. Und das mit dem Überzeugen deiner Freunde, die natürlich dabei auch mitmachen müssen, ja, ist auch ein Riesenproblem. Also ich habe irgendwie jahrelang ein PGP-Keyring mit mir rumgeschleppt. Da hatte ich fünf Schlüssel drin. Und das war echt einsam und traurig. Und ich habe das nur aus Überzeugung gemacht. Inzwischen habe ich da mehrere hundert Schlüssel und das ist super. Und das dauert einfach seine Zeit. Aber man sollte es nicht aufgeben.
Ja, also A, was mir z.B. fehlt, ist sowas wie eine Anlaufstelle. Weil es ist sowas wie, nehmen wir mal GPG, wo ich mir so denke, mit Android-Telefon kannst du es endlich vernünftig machen im Gegensatz zu iOS. Und dann lest du halt irgendwie, ja, bist du bescheuert, dass du irgendwie deinen Private Key auf deinem Telefon speicherst. Weil Telefone sind halt so generell eher unsicher.
Nils, ich würde dich jetzt gerne nicht in die Details privater Verschwindungstechnologien einziehen, weil die Zeit uns zu sagen, ich weiß, wie viele noch geplant haben und es schon langsam wieder fortläuft. Und würde deswegen zum Schluss kommen wollen und sagen wollen, also sagen die Runde hier empfiehlt, man darf ein bisschen resignieren, man sollte es aber nicht ganz aufgeben. Kannst du damit leben? Ja, mal sehen.
Es fehlt halt die Anlaufstelle. Das, was du ja auch schon gefragt hattest mit dem, ja und was empfiehlt dir so? Da gibt es irgendwie, es gibt halt so eine, eine, die ich weiß nicht, ob es Tactical Tech ist oder es gab irgendwie mal was, was so ein bisschen die Runde machte, ist aber so richtig auch nicht meiner Meinung nach.
Na, Prison Break zum Beispiel finde ich, ist eine ganz vernünftige Anlaufstelle.
Ja genau, Prison Break war es ja auch.
Beispielsweise, dann gibt es echt eine ganze Menge andere Sachen von Tactical Tech, gibt es Security in a Box, wo eine Reihe von Softwarevorgestellten auch erklärt wird und so ein bisschen für Einsteiger, um nachzuvollziehen, wie funktioniert Tracking und wie ist das mit den Browser Addons und so, würde ich empfehlen, myshadow.org, da wird das relativ gut erklärt.
Und viel Glück dabei. Bis dann. So, Gottes Willen, wer hätte das gedacht? Mit Hörern heute.
Mit einem Hörern.
Na, es ist noch einer in der Leitung, tatsächlich. Der möge sich mit noch ein bisschen gedulden. Wir spielen jetzt eine ganz kurze Musik, machen dann den Nerdnews und dann geht es hier weiter in Chaosradio in Blumen. Die Musik ist ein besonderer Wunsch des Herrn Meister. NoFX, Vanilla Sky kommt jetzt. Kannst du kurz noch erklären, warum wir das jetzt hören?
Weil es darin unter anderem Privacy geht, aber auch im Porn, also um das Internet.
Na dann, hören wir mal rein. Norfix mit Vanilla Sex auf besonderen Wunsch eines Gastes hier im Chaosradio in Blue Moon. Und das wäre natürlich nicht dasselbe, das Chaosradio in Blue Moon ohne die Nerd News, geschrieben vom Chaos Computer Club, präsentiert von Scarlett Kubosik.
Die sogenannte Logjam-Lücke erlaubt es Angreifern, sichere Netzverbindungen zu belauschen und zu manipulieren. Durch diese Lücke lassen sich nämlich Server durch Dritte dazu überreden, schwache Kryptographie zu verwenden, die sich dann einfach knacken lässt. Die Browser-Hersteller arbeiten derzeit an Updates, Microsoft hat den Internet Explorer bereits aktualisiert. Grundlage für die Sicherheitslücke ist veralteter Programm-Code aus den 90er Jahren, der in vielen Servern immer noch verwendet wird. Experten raten deswegen Serverbetreibern dazu, diese Export-Zeifer abzuschalten. Eine neue Malware attackiert Router, die kleinen Plastikkästchen, die bei euch zu Hause das Internet in der Wohnung verteilen. Neu ist dabei, dass die Shard-Software in der Lage ist, über 50 Modelle fast aller großen Hersteller anzugreifen. Bei den befallenen Routern wird der komplette Internetverkehr umgeleitet oder verändert. Man fängt sich dieser Shard-Software ganz einfach ein, auf entsprechend präparierten Webseiten, versucht die Malware das Modell des Routers herauszufinden und attackiert es gezielt. Findet sie dabei keine Schwachstelle, probiert sie noch das Passwort durch raten herauszufinden. Deshalb gilt immer schön updaten und sichere Passwörter verwenden. Auf den Namen TOX hört ein neuer Dienst, mit dem sicher ein Erpressertrojaner bauen und ihn personalisieren und versenden lassen kann. Möchte gern Erpresser, können beliebigen Leuten einen angepassten Trojaner zusenden lassen, inklusive persönlicher Nachricht. Wird der Trojaner aktiviert, verschlüsselt dieser wichtige Dokumente auf dem Rechner der Opfer. Für die Freigabe der Daten wird eine Zahlung per Bitcoin an die Toxmacher verlangt. Diese behalten davon 30 Prozent für ihre Dienstleistung ein. Der Rest soll angeblich anonym an den Auftraggeber gehen. Besonders perfide, da die Schadsoftware jedes Mal neu verfasst wird, wird sie von Virenscannern und anderer Sicherheitssoftware kaum entdeckt.
Scarlet Kubosik präsentierte die Nerd News vom Chaos Computer Club. Und falls jetzt jemand zur letzten Meldung sagen will, wie könnt ihr es nur wagen, so was den Hörern vorzuschlagen, das ist als Sicherheitswarnung gedacht, nicht als Leitfaden. Ich hoffe, das ist klar. Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaosradio im Blue Moon hier auf Fritz, wo wir heute über Snowden reden. Seit zwei Jahren gibt es die Leaks und wir reden ein bisschen darüber, wie es so war, was die Konsequenzen daraus sind und was man daraus vielleicht lernen kann. Zur Gast sind heute Anne Roth, sie arbeitet als Referentin für Die Linke beim NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Andre Meister von netzpolitik.org. Hallo und guten Abend.
Und Linus Neumann vom Chaos Computer Club. Und wir haben jetzt sozusagen schon die Historie beleuchtet und haben ein bisschen über die Technik geredet, also die technischen Änderungen, die sich heraus ergeben, und wollen dann gleich zur politischen Aufarbeitung schreiben, die wir international schon ein bisschen beleuchtet hatten. Vorher aber haben wir noch Fabian hier in der Leitung, der angerufen hat, konnte er auch noch gerne machen, unter 0331 77 97 120, der was erzählen wollte dazu, wie es in seinem Umfeld die Reaktionen auf Snowden waren. Hallo und guten Abend, Fabian.
Du hast ganz am Anfang gefragt, wie ist denn, also deswegen habe ich da gedacht, ob ich das fragen kann. Das ist in meinem Umfeld eigentlich nicht unspektakulär gewesen, direkt nach Snowden, weil ich in verschiedenen Bubbles unterwegs bin. Und zum einen ist da die Bubble Stuttgarter Bahnhofswiderstand. Dann haben wir da die Bubble, ich bin selbstständig und habe Kunden, die in der Industrie arbeiten und in großen Firmen, renommierten Firmen. Und ich habe dann mein normales soziales Umfeld auf dem Dorf. Und spannend, oder was ich immer nicht mitteilen wollte, warum mache ich das gar nicht mehr, ist eigentlich, die allererste Reaktion auf dem Dorf ist, ja und aber Griechenland.
Das ist ja eine relativ aktuelle Diskussion. Am Anfang hat dir das gar nicht interessiert, oder wie?
Meine Analyse ist eigentlich, das befordert die Leute. Mich ja eigentlich auch, ich ringe hier am Chaos Computer Group Radio und fahre von einem ins Letzte mit dem anderen. Ich habe mir das letzte halbe Jahr sämtliche online stehenden Podcasts angehört. Den einen intensiver, den anderen weniger. Und habe dann auch mich entschieden, ich gehe jetzt machen ja ein Auf-Globe-PG und juckele da jetzt mit meinen zwei im Kurs, ich habe eigentlich keinen Sinn, also ich finde einfach keinen, der mit mir zum Schlüssel. Ich versuche aus der ganzen Zeit WhatsApp aufzulösen. Also meine Firma zum Beispiel wird dann automatisch von den Kunden teilweise angeschrieben per Shortmessage. Und bisher hatte man eben WhatsApp. Und ich habe es großartig angekündigt, ich verlängere das nicht mehr. Ich kille das aus, Schlussende vorbei. Und die Reaktion ist, sie schicken es dann halt per SMS anstatt per E-Mail. Oder irgendeine andere Alternative zu nehmen. Wo ich mir dann gedacht habe, das hat es jetzt nicht gebracht. Dann hätten wir auch bei WhatsApp bleiben können sozusagen. Bei meiner Adresse, die ja sowieso am eingestellt haben. Ich glaube, dass da in meinem Umfeld das ganze Komplex eigentlich gar nicht bekannt ist. Und wenn man jetzt zum Snowden spricht, ist man, wie vorher in euren Gesprächen ja schon rausgekommen, ist ja gleich auf einer ganz anderen Ebene, die einem persönlich gar nichts mehr angeht. Wenn man jetzt nicht der Aktivist ist, dann geht einem das eigentlich gar nichts an. Dann ist das so was wie Volkszählen. Und wenn ich das damit vergleiche, in meinem persönlichen direkten Umfeld, die Nummer mit Volkszählen, dann hat man ganz viele andere Probleme. Also dann ist es irgendwie wichtiger, was mit dem Euro passiert, und dann ist irgendwie wichtiger die Elbphilharmonie oder whatever. Das sind dann noch Steuergelder, wo die Menschen der Meinung sind, dass das ihr Geld mal war oder ist. Und das finden wir dann im Endeffekt wichtiger. Also ich habe in meinem persönlichen Umfeld niemanden, nicht einen einzigen, davon Bezug gekriegt WhatsApp zu verlassen, aus den bekannten Gründen. Ich müsste sie ja alle mitnehmen und dann zuteilen sie sich und dann habe ich sie nicht mehr.
Also sagen wir bei dir auch eher ein resigniertes Fazit aus dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Du rennst so gegen eine Wand.
Du rennst so gegen eine Wissenswand.
Das kriegst du ja gar nicht.
Das bringt uns ja genau wieder dazu, dass wir eigentlich mal auch darüber reden müssten, wie man es politisch macht. Weil, sagen wir, wir haben schon festgestellt, also technisch geht es sowieso nicht ganz. Inhaltlich funktioniert es nicht so gut, weil sagen jetzt schon zwei Leute sagen, naja, also es funktioniert für mich nicht so richtig gut, es funktioniert auch im Umfeld nicht so richtig gut. Deswegen würden wir uns dann, glaube ich, jetzt mal der Politik wenden. Fabian, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für den Einblick in deine Filter-Bubblen. Und mal gucken, was draus wird.
Da war ja nur eine. Ich hätte ja noch zwei. Aber gut, okay, ich lasse dich in deinem Programm weiter machen.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen deprimierend auch. Ist es für euch eigentlich noch deprimierend, das zu hören, dass Leute anrufen und sagen, zwei Jahre danach gibt es immer noch viele Menschen, denen das eigentlich Latte ist, weil Griechenland ist viel gefährlicher?
Das gibt es ja bei jedem Thema. Ich kenne auch Menschen, denen Griechenland Latte ist. Und ich kenne eine ganze Menge Menschen, denen das Schicksal der Hühner, die sie essen, Latte ist. Das ist, glaube ich, bei jedem politischen Thema genauso. Es gibt immer einen Teil Menschen, die sich für das Thema interessieren, die darin eine Gefahr sehen und eine Menge Verbesserungspotenzial, das sie gerne erreichen möchten. Und das Ziel ist einfach nur, dieses Verbesserungspotenzial zu erreichen, damit alle davon profitieren. Und das, worauf, denke ich, wir alle drei, aber Andre und Anne, insbesondere, hinarbeiten, ist ja das genau, da eine Verbesserung eintritt, von der am Ende alle profitieren und da wird dann auch nicht differenziert werden nach der Revolution. Wer das jetzt vorher wollte oder nicht, das machen wir für alle.
Okay, so, dann kommen wir jetzt zu dem Thema, was schon ganz oft angesprochen wurde und was wir jetzt mal näher beleuchten wollen.
Revolutionstheorien.
Nein, den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Herrgott nochmal, wir brauchen mehr Sendezeit. Flo Heiler, der nach uns senden wird, der braucht heute glaube ich, der muss keine Musik spielen. Nein, im Ernst, NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Also es gibt politische Außerarbeitung. Ich wollte vorher eigentlich, vielleicht können wir es noch ganz kurz beleuchten, bevor wir dazu kommen. Die Politik sagt ja immer so, also Politik ungeheim, die sagen ja so generell so, also tendenziell, ne, wir machen da, also die anderen sind die Bösen, wir machen eigentlich alles richtig, also hier in Deutschland und dann kommt so Schritt für Schritt raus. Das ist ja doch gar nicht so. Hängt das alles mit dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss auch zusammen oder ist da auch noch über andere Ecken was rausgekommen?
Ich habe die Frage nicht verstanden.
Na also die Politik, wenn ich die Politik in Deutschland beobachte, ist es so, die sagen erst mal so, ne, wir wissen von nichts und wir machen auch nichts Ungesetzliches. Und dann kommt Schritt für Schritt raus, naja, das stimmt nicht ganz, das stimmt eigentlich ganz schön doll nicht, das stimmt eigentlich überhaupt nicht. Ist das das Ergebnis, was der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss bringt oder gibt es da noch andere Wege, durch die das forciert wurde?
Na, also ich glaube, dieses Mantra der Bundesregierung, alles ist voll rechtmäßig und alles ist genau richtig und wir halten uns an alle Gesetze und die Amerikaner auch und überhaupt alle. Das ist sozusagen das Mantra, was erstmal vorgetragen wird, um zu hoffen, dass damit möglichst viele Leute das glauben und einfach nicht weiter nachfragen und denken, das hat schon alles seine Richtigkeit, die machen das schon. Und das dann nebenbei jetzt doch eine ganze Menge rausgekommen ist, wo doch sehr deutlich geworden ist, das haut nicht hin, irgendwer hält sich nicht an Gesetze. Und dahinter dann noch die Frage, ist das schon alles, was wir wollen, dass sich an diese Gesetze gehalten wird? Oder ist auch bei den Gesetzen vielleicht noch so ein bisschen der Wurm drin? Weil die ganz schön viel Überwachung auch ermöglichen und viel unkontrollierten Geheimdienst, der alles Mögliche macht, aber nichts darüber verrät, was das ist. Selbst wenn das jetzt also voll rechtmäßig wäre und die sich an alles hielten, ist das immer noch nicht das, was ich will. Und das ist jetzt aber natürlich nicht nur der Untersuchungsausschuss, der das herausgefunden hat, sondern doch auch eine ganze Menge anderer. Eben angefangen mit Snowden, der das Thema aufgebracht hat. Ganz viele Leute, die nachfragen, ganz viele Leute, die darüber berichten. Und auch andere Gremien, also auch allein die parlamentarische Aufarbeitung findet ja nicht nur im Untersuchungsausschuss statt, sondern über Fragen an die Bundesregierung der Abgeordneten, über die anderen Ausschüsse auch, Innenausschuss und so weiter. Dann gibt es noch die anderen Kontrollgremien, wobei bei denen eben der Haken ist, dass sie völlig nicht öffentlich sind und kein Mensch weiß, was da stattfindet und auch nie erfahren wird. Aber die alle bohren natürlich jetzt gerade darum.
Aber das bekannteste Instrument, wenn man jetzt öffentliche Berichterstattung verfolgt, ist schon dieser NS-Untersuchungsausschuss. Und jetzt könnt ihr bitte mal erzählen, was passiert da eigentlich genau eigentlich, wozu ist der gut, was macht ihr da und überhaupt?
Es war einmal.
Also wie ist es überhaupt dazu gekommen?
Na Snowden, ne? Juni 2013 war Snowden und dann hatten wir Wahlkampf. Und dann hat Pofalla die Affäre für beendet erklärt. Und andere haben erklärt, dass unter Freunden nicht spioniert wird. Und dann gab es eine Wahl, die für die Koalition ganz gut gelaufen ist, weil wir jetzt eine 80-prozentige Mehrheit der großen Koalition von SPD und CDU haben. Und ich glaube, wenn diese Wahl nicht zwei Monate nach Snowden gewesen wäre, wäre es vielleicht nicht unbedingt zu so einem Untersuchungsausschuss gekommen. Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht täusche ich mich da auch. Aber ich denke, dass das damit dazu zu tun hatte, dass es eben einstimmig, also durch alle Fraktionen, die Entscheidung gab, dass so ein Untersuchungsausschuss eingerichtet werden soll. Die ganze Debatte darüber hat, nachdem sich das Parlament so ein bisschen sortiert hat, der erstmal auch eine ganze Weile gedauert. Und dann im März 2014 hat das Parlament mit allen Stimmen aller Fraktionen eben beschlossen, es gibt einen Untersuchungsausschuss. Und der hat dann vor jetzt einem guten Jahr seine Arbeit angefangen.
Jetzt, der heißt ja NSL-Untersuchungsausschuss. Man hört aber immer Ergebnisse...
Nee, heißt der nicht. Der heißt Erster Parlamentarischer Untersuchungsausschuss. Erster PUA. Fertig aus.
Legislaturperiode.
Genau, der wird genannt, NSL-Untersuchungsausschuss. Also NSL kommt da sozusagen... Ich meine, es geht ja nicht nur um die NSA. Es geht um die Five Eyes, also um diesen Geheimdienstverbund aus fünf Staaten. Und inzwischen, finde ich, müsste man den eher BND-Untersuchungsausschuss nennen oder Massenüberwachungsuntersuchungsausschuss oder...
Okay, danke, dass du die Frage beantwortest. Was ist denn eigentlich der Auftrag?
Der Auftrag sind acht Seiten. Hör ich ja dabei. Ich hab einen Zettel, wo ich sämtliche Punkte, weil ich das selber auch immer nicht alles flüssig hin gehe. Es gibt drei Teile in diesem Untersuchungsauftrag. Der erste ist im Grunde, dass das untersucht werden soll, was diese Überwachung durch die Five Eyes starten. Also USA, Großbritannien sind die bekanntesten, Kanada, Australien, Neuseeland gehören auch noch mit dazu. Das ist dieser sehr eng zusammen arbeitende Geheimdienstverbund. Also diese Überwachung durch die Five Eyes untersuchen soll. Und da drin gibt es dann eine ganze Reihe von Unterpunkten. Die interessantesten dabei sind auch die Beteiligung am Geheimen Krieg, also dem Drohnenkrieg, der in Deutschland über die US-Basis in Rammstein geführt wird, inwieweit der BND oder die deutsche Regierung daran mit beteiligt sind. Ein anderer, finde ich, ziemlich relevanter Unterpunkt ist die Rolle der Flüchtlingsbefragungen, an denen auch Vertreter der Five Eyes beteiligt sind, mit ganz klassischem Aufklärungsinteresse aus diesen Flüchtlingsbefragungen. Wenn Leute aus Regionen hierher kommen, die Zielregionen der NSA sind, dann haben die halt bestimmte Fragen an diese Flüchtlinge. Das soll auch mit aufgeklärt werden. Und ansonsten geht es aber eben ganz viel um Erkenntnisse über Überwachung gegen Unternehmen und wie sich davor technisch geschützt wurde und was die Bundesregierung darüber bisher wusste und was sie dagegen tut und zu tun gedenkt und so weiter. Also da gibt es eine ganze Reihe von Unterpunkten, die sich alle mit dieser Überwachung durch die Five Eyes beschäftigen. Der zweite Punkt des Auftrages ist konkret die Überwachung der Bundesregierung selbst, des Bundes als solchen und seiner Institutionen, der Parlamentarier und der Verfassungsorgane ganz gezielt durch die Five Eyes. Und der dritte Teil des Untersuchungsauftrages sind dann Empfehlungen zur Wahrung der informationellen Selbstbestimmung und der Privatsphäre. Das heißt, da soll es einen Empfehlungsteil geben, das würde der CCC jetzt nicht machen, aber jedenfalls das Untersuchungsausschuss hat als Aufgabe, Empfehlungen für die Bundesregierung und für den Bundestag zu entwickeln, zu sagen, folgende Fehler haben wir gefunden und das sollte passieren, damit das nicht mehr vorkommt.
Andre, du beobachtest dieses Ding ja für nestpolitik.org. Also du sitzt immer bei den öffentlichen Sitzungen da und bloggst live und machst hinterher sozusagen eine Riesenzusammenfassung. Was genau passiert in diesem Ausschuss oder was ist passiert bis jetzt?
Tja, vielleicht mal kurz zu meiner Rolle, weil du es ansprichst. Also es gibt manche Sitzungen mit Zeugen und Sachverständigen, die tagen öffentlich. Da kann jeder hingehen. Also nicht nur Journalisten. Da kann sich jeder auf der Webseite des Bundestages und des Untersuchungsausschusses einfach anmelden. Eine E-Mail reicht. Also wenn die öffentlich tagen, kann da auch wirklich jeder hin. Das kann ich auch nur empfehlen. Das Problem ist, dass es davon keine offiziellen Mitschnitte gibt. Nichts veröffentlicht wird, kein Video oder Audio oder so. Und dass man quasi nur das mitnehmen kann, was man mitschreiben kann. Also versuchen wir, möglichst alles mitzuschreiben und möglichst live ins Internet zu stellen, weil wir haben da genug Platz. Und das macht Spaß, ist interessant. Wird aber auch ganz gut nachgefragt. Und da jetzt die Frage, was der Ausschuss in einem Jahr Arbeit herausbekommen hat, beim Blick auf die Sendezeit, sollten wir vielleicht bei den allerwichtigsten Punkten bleiben. Also es ging tatsächlich schon mal los mit einem ziemlichen Paukenschlag. Bei der allerersten öffentlichen Sitzung kamen die drei Granden der deutschen Verfassungsrechtler und haben alle unisono erklärt, also die gesamte Auslandsaufklärung des BND ist eigentlich komplett rechtswidrig. Da haben dann auch die Vertreter der großen Koalition ein bisschen gestaunt, weil die haben ja zwei von denen eingeladen und die Opposition zusammen nur eine, weil so sind nun mal die Mehrheitsverhältnisse in diesem Parlament, 80 zu 20. Dementsprechend sind dann auch die Zeitbudgets und die Zeugen und Sachverständigen von der Opposition nur ziemlich dürftig. Trotzdem haben die alle gesagt, dass es komplett illegal, wie der BND im Ausland agiert. Zumindest gibt es keine rechtliche Basis. Das war schon mal ein krasser Auftakt. Und dann kamen nach und nach Zeugen von Telekom, Dezix, aber vor allem auch eben BND, die erklären mussten, mal mehr, mal weniger enthusiastisch, wie denn das nun vonstattengeht, wie der BND involviert ist in die Massenüberwachung, welche Kabel angezapft werden, welche Satellitenstrecken angezapft werden und welche Informationen dadurch an andere Dienste, meistens die USA im Sinne von NSA und CIA, gegeben werden. Und dann das neueste große Thema ist das mit den sogenannten Selektoren, was jetzt in den letzten Wochen hochgeploppt ist. Aber da ist dann viel Detailarbeit für den Ausschuss. Die haben irgendwie hunderttausende Aktenordner, soweit ich das höre, wo man sich durchkämpfen muss, was halt irgendwie als Opposition mit drei, vier Leuten nicht so wirklich gut zu machen ist. Und dann gibt es teilweise Zeugen da drin von BND, die eine Frage kriegen und dann gucken sie nach links zur Bundesregierung, kriegen den Signal und sagen dann ins Mikrofon, habe ich vergessen. Solche Dinge passieren in dem Ausschuss. Es ist dann nicht immer ganz einfach, den Überblick zu behalten in den Details. Aber immerhin haben wir mit der Feststellung, dass der BND rechtswidrig im Ausland agiert. Und durch so Operationen wie Iconal und Gloteig, zu denen wir schon ein bisschen was gehört haben, also Glasfaserabschmuschel-Aktionen, jetzt mal herausbekommen, wie der BND arbeitet. Und das ist schon mal ein guter Schritt auf den Weg zur Aufklärung, wie wir dann in dem nächsten Schritt eben damit umgeben, was daraus folgt, welche politischen Konsequenzen gezogen werden.
Gibt es eigentlich eine Begründung dafür, dass dieser Ausschuss öffentlich ist, aber irgendwie nicht offiziell dokumentiert wird? Also die anderen öffentlichen Geschehnisse, die ich so an den Bundestag verfolge oder mal teilgenommen habe, die wurden eigentlich durchaus dann auch dokumentiert öffentlich gemacht.
Ja, das ist so eine rechtliche Verdrehung. Die Zeugen, die da geladen werden, die werden so ähnlich wie in einem Gerichtsverfahren vernommen. Und die offizielle Ansage ist, dass sich kommende Zeugen nicht über die Aussagen der vorherigen Zeugen informieren sollen, damit die unbefangen, unabgesprochen, unabhängig voneinander aussagen. Das ist auch der Grund, warum die offiziellen Protokolle leider nicht veröffentlicht werden. Nur sagen alle BND-Zeugen offen im Ausschuss, die lesen halt unsere Protokolle auf Netzpolitikruck. Diese Ausrede hat sich dann auch gegessen. Aber irgendwann werden auch die Protokolle der Zeugenvernehmungen der öffentlichen Teile veröffentlicht, und zwar spätestens mit dem Abschlussbericht dieses Untersuchungsausschusses.
Jetzt ist Andre da als sozusagen öffentlicher Beobachter. Du bist Fachreferentin für die Fraktion Die Linke. Was genau ist da deine Aufgabe?
Ja, einfach alles, was mit dem Ausschuss zu tun hat, irgendwie im Auge zu behalten, zu koordinieren, die Akten zu lesen, die Abgeordneten mit den notwendigen Informationen zu versorgen, auch Fragenkataloge für die Ausschusssitzungen zu schreiben, auch so ganz banalen Kram wie, es gibt geheime Akten, die müssen aus der Geheimschutzstelle abgeholt und ins Büro getragen werden. Ich bin die einzige Referentin, dann gibt es aber noch ein paar Mitarbeiter, zwei, die solche Sachen machen dürfen, einfach einen Überblick behalten. Dann gibt es Referententreffen von den Referenten der verschiedenen Fraktionen, die im Grunde vorbesprechen, was die Abgeordneten dann im Ausschuss machen. Es gibt ja einerseits die öffentlichen Anhörungen, die bei Netzpolitik beschrieben werden, über die berichtet wird auch viel in der Presse. Und daneben gibt es aber natürlich auch noch nicht öffentliche Sitzungen und Obleutesitzungen, wo entschieden wird beispielsweise, welche Zeugen eigentlich geladen werden, welche Themen eigentlich aufgerufen werden, wo bestimmte Fragen gestellt werden, wo ganz viele Auseinandersetzungen mit der Bundesregierung auch stattfinden, darüber, dass die Akten, ganz viel in den Akten geschwärzt ist, dass es da eine ganze Reihe von Verfahrensproblemen gibt, wo die Bundesregierung die Arbeit des Ausschusses behindert und wo die Abgeordneten sich darüber beschweren. Diese ganzen Auseinandersetzungen darüber, ob Snowden als Zeuge in den Ausschuss geladen wird, was ja dann in der Verfassungsklage der Opposition gipfelte, hat auch in diesen nicht öffentlichen Sitzungen stattgefunden. Und das wird dann eben von Referenten vorbereitet. Und das ist auch mit meinem Job.
Das ist auch mal interessant zu wissen. Also da sitzen dann gar keine MdBs, also Bundestagsabgeordneten mit drin, sondern die erfahren alles, was in diesem Ausschuss passiert, noch mal durch eine Filter-Ebene, nämlich genau die Referenten, die für die Abgeordneten oder für die Fraktionen dann da sitzen.
Na, es gibt beides. Es gibt sozusagen diese Referententreffen. Und dann gibt es die Obleutetreffen, wo sozusagen für jede Fraktion gibt es einen Obmann oder eine Obfrau, sozusagen Sprecher der Fraktion im Ausschuss. Und diese vier vorbesprechen bestimmte Sachen, die vorher von den Referenten vorbesprochen wurden, was einfach damit zu tun hat, dass MdBs... Also ich finde, das hat durchaus Sinn. Dafür gibt es ja Mitarbeiter im Parlament, weil MdBs einfach hier auch nicht nur diesen einen Ausschuss haben, sondern gerade in den kleinen Fraktionen noch eine ganze Reihe von anderen Ausschüssen und Funktionen. Und eine Dichte von Themen an einem Tag zu verarbeiten haben, was mich persönlich ziemlich stressen würde, muss ich sagen, obwohl ich das auch so schon ganz ordentlich intensiv finde. Insofern ist das schon sinnvoll, dass es Leute gibt, die das sozusagen so ein bisschen vorkauen, sage ich mal. Und das natürlich aber auch vorher mit den MdBs jeweils innerhalb der Fraktionen besprechen. Und genau, das wird dann eben in diesen nichtöffentlichen Sitzungen letztlich beschlossen. Und daraus entstehen dann die Tagesordnung und öffentliche Anhörungen.
Es sind jetzt dieses Werkzeug unserer Demokratie. Wenn man so Meinung darüber hat, dann schwankt das zwischen diesen beiden Extremen. Das ist genau super, das ist genau das, was wir brauchen. Und der zahnlose Papiermonster bringt eigentlich nichts. Da reden halt Leute vieler Namen. Wie ist eure Meinung dazu? Ist das jetzt das richtige Werkzeug? Bringt das die Ergebnisse, die ihr euch gewünscht habt? Also vielleicht nicht die Ergebnisse, die ihr euch inhaltlich gewünscht habt, aber sozusagen zumindest wird das bearbeitet, was ihr euch gewünscht habt?
Also ich finde es schon cool, dass es diesen Ausschuss gibt, sonst hätte ich auch diesen Job nicht machen wollen. Das ist ja nicht erzwungen über mich gekommen, sondern ich wollte das gerne machen, weil ich das als Thema total spannend fand, die Möglichkeit überhaupt parlamentarisch aufzuarbeiten und über ein schon relativ gut ausgerüstetes parlamentarisches Instrument untersuchen zu können, was die Regierung und was der Geheimdienst da macht und wie das alles mit der Massenüberwachung der NSA und den Enthüllungen von Snowden zusammenhängt. Das ist eine ziemlich einmalige Gelegenheit, finde ich. Und deswegen fand ich das und finde ich das sehr spannend. Nicht nur, weil ich Einblick in irgendwelche geheimen Dokumente habe, sondern wegen der Sachen, die dabei rauskommen. Und gleichzeitig ist es so, dass eben wegen der Mehrheitsverhältnisse, so wie sie sind, in diesem Ausschuss sind acht Abgeordnete plus Stellvertreter. Davon sind vier von der Union, zwei von der SPD, eine von den Linken und einer von den Grünen. Und es wird in der Regel nach Mehrheit entschieden, wenn nicht gemeinsam entschieden wird. Es gibt häufig Einigungsprozesse, deswegen sind diese Vorbesprechungen auch wichtig, wo gesagt wird, wir gemeinsam wollen bestimmte Zeugen vernehmen. Was die Motive sind, warum wir das wollen versus warum die Union das will, die sind vielleicht noch mal unterschiedlich an bestimmten Punkten, die sich vielleicht auch keine Blöße geben, weil sie natürlich auch als Abgeordnete der Union in diesem Ausschuss sind, erst mal nach außen hin mit dem Auftrag, das aufzuklären, der gewesenen Oppmann Kiesewetter hat immer sehr deutlich gesagt, dass sein Interesse ist, mit dem Ausschuss zu belegen, dass alles in Ordnung ist. Klar ist das ein unterschiedliches Motiv und klar sind wir uns denn nicht unbedingt einig, immer einig gewesen, was das Vorgehen angeht, aber zumindest ist das pro forma erstmal so. Und jetzt habe ich einen Faden verloren.
Also es geht um die Endkündigung, ob das sozusagen ein scharfes Werkzeug ist. Ich nehme dein Wort und so, es könnte besser sein, aber für die Situation, in der wir uns befinden, ist es schon auch gut genug.
Ich finde, es ist zumindest erstmal, ist das ein Instrument, was wir haben und das sollten wir nutzen, deswegen tun wir das. Und ich finde übrigens, dass es schon jetzt nach einem Jahr sehr viel mehr rausgekommen ist, als ich eigentlich erwartet hatte, weil ich eben genau wegen dieser Mehrheitsverhältnisse, deswegen bin ich jetzt darauf gekommen, damit gerechnet habe, dass wir eigentlich gar nichts rauskriegen. Der Ausschuss ist davon abhängig, dass die Bundesregierung bestimmte Dokumente aushändigt. Und auch wenn sie rechtlich dazu verpflichtet sind, alle Dokumente auszuhändigen, nach denen, die der Ausschuss haben will, weil Parlament kontrolliert Regierung, deswegen kann Parlament sagen, Regierung, gib mal her. Ist das natürlich nicht kontrollierbar und ob das dann alles ist, ist immer zweifelhaft. Es hat auch schon Fälle gegeben, mehrfach jetzt im Ausschuss, wo wir im Nachhinein festgestellt haben, da haben sie was vergessen, da haben sie was übersehen, da sind ein paar Ordner untergegangen und dann hat aus Versehen ein Zeuge drüber geredet und dann konnten sie nicht mehr verheimlichen, dass es die gibt und mussten diese zusätzlichen Dokumente dann auch... Also das gibt es. Dazu gibt es die Mehrheitsverhältnisse. Das heißt, wenn es Sachen gibt, die der Regierung zu deutlich gegen den Strich gehen, dann steht natürlich die Koalition bei Fuß und sagt, gibt es nicht. Da ist jetzt diese Selektoren-Geschichte ein ganz typisches Beispiel. Die SPD pöbelt ganz laut rum und im Ausschuss stimmen sie aber immer mit der Union gegen die Anträge der Opposition und verhindern damit eine Einsicht in diese Selektorenlisten oder überhaupt eine Lösung, wie durch den Ausschuss eingesehen werden kann, worum es bei diesen Selektorenlisten gibt. Diese Mehrheitsverhältnisse sind so und damit haben wir eigentlich eine relativ schwierige Situation für die Aufklärung. Denn die Koalitionsparteien, also Fraktionen, SPD und Union, schützen natürlich ihre Regierung. Die Parlamentarier haben durchaus teilweise, würde ich sagen, schon in ihrer Parlamentarier-Ähre und die ist in der Regel bei MDB sehr ausgeprägt, natürlich in dieser Rolle auch ein bisschen ein Interesse, was aufzuklären. Aber wenn es um irgendwas Interessantes geht, dann schützen sie die Regierung. Damit haben wir als Opposition relativ wenig Chance.
Also Verfahrensfehler werden wahrscheinlich aufgeklärt, aber die Revolution würde nicht stattfinden.
Genau, ich glaube, die Revolution kann ein parlamentarischer Ausschuss sowieso nicht anleuten. Das widerspricht sich vollständig. Sowas kann ein Ausschuss nicht machen. Das muss die Öffentlichkeit, das muss die Bevölkerung machen, wenn sie es denn haben will. Also nur grundsätzlich verändern muss sie auch ihren Willen deutlich machen, nicht nur über die Wahl, sondern z.B. Demonstrationen und deutlichere Willensbekundungen. Aber der Ausschuss kann ziemlich viel aufklären. Und da ist echt erstaunlich viel schon zutage gekommen.
Okay, dann will ich gleich nochmal genauer wissen, was für dich diese Ergebnisse sind, wo du sagst, okay, das ist schon erstaunlich, dass du das rausgefunden hast. Wir machen erst nochmal eine letzte kleine Pause mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Dann geht es hier nochmal eine halbe Stunde weiter im Chaosradio im Blue Moon.
Das Line-up ist komplett. Und verrückte Welt. Die neuen Deutschpoeten sind gar nicht neun, sondern sogar zehn.
Die neuen Deutschpoeten.
Yandilay. Bilderbuch.
Und Anne-Malcantereit.
Tonbandgerät. Die neuen Deutschpoeten.
Freitag, Vierter und Samstag, Fünfter, September. Live im IFRA Sommergarten der Messe Berlin.
Solang's noch Karten gibt.
Gibt's Karten im Kombi-Ticket für beide Tage. Oder einzeln für Freitag oder Samstag. fritz.de slash deutschpoeten.
Die neuen Deutschpoeten.
Das fritz Open Air Festival.
Immer gute neue Musik. Fritz Nachrichten.
FIFA-Präsident Blatter hat zum ersten Mal etwas zum Korruptionsskandal gesagt. Zu Beginn des FIFA-Kongresses in Zürich sagte er, dass er sich nichts vorzuwerfen hat. Den Korruptionsskandal bezeichnet er als eine Schande für den Fußball. Der Europäische Fußballverband UEFA hatte Blatter heute aufgefordert, zurückzutreten. Morgen stellt sich Blatter beim FIFA-Kongress für eine fünfte Amtszeit zur Wahl. Die UEFA dann gekündigt, ihn nicht zu wählen. Verfassungsschützer fordern, dass junge Leute besser über Propaganda von Extremisten aufgeklärt werden. Rechtsextremisten und Terrorgruppen wie der Islamische Staat nutzen immer stärker YouTube und Facebook, um Jugendliche anzuwerben. Über dieses Problem wurde heute bei einer Tagung der ostdeutschen Verfassungsschutzbehörden in Potsdam gesprochen. Experten warnen davor, dass Extremisten über das Internet in Sekunden schnelle Jugendliche überall auf der Welt erreichen und beeinflussen können. Waffen an Bord eines Flugzeugs zu schmuggeln, ist in Deutschland wie es aussieht einfacher als in anderen europäischen Ländern. Das sagt die EU-Kommission. Sie hatte im Dezember verdeckte Prüfer zum Frankfurter Flughafen geschickt. Bei jedem zweiten Versuch gelang es ihnen Waffen oder andere verbotene Gegenstände mit an Bord zu nehmen. Weil bisher nichts dagegen die mangelhaften Passagierkontrollen getan wurde, verklagt die EU-Kommission Deutschland jetzt vor dem Europäischen Gerichtshof. In der Fußball-Bundesliga war am Abend die Hinrunde der Relegation. Das Spiel Hamburg gegen Karlsruhe ist 1 zu 1 ausgegangen. Die Entscheidung darüber, ob der Hamburger Verein zum ersten Mal in seiner Geschichte in die zweite Liga absteigt und Karlsruhe aufsteigt, fällt jetzt beim Rückspiel, das ist am Montag. Alba Berlin hat im Halbfinalduell der Basketball-Bundesliga gegen Bayern München verloren, 73 zu 85 ist es ausgegangen, damit steht es in der Best of 5 Serie 1 zu 1. Das Wetter Wir haben in Berlin-Rheinikendorf 11 und in Treptow 12 Grad, Falkensee und Bad Freienwalde 10, Bielezeitstätten 11, Cottbus 13 Grad. In der Nacht kann es immer mal wieder regnen, bei Temperaturen zwischen 10 und 4 Grad minimal. Morgen wird es dann wechselhaft, es gibt Sonne, Wolken und Regen bei 18 bis höchstens 22 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin 100, Stadtring Richtung Wedding zwischen Kurfürstendamm und Dreieck Funkturm sind zwei Spuren gesperrt. 111 Stadtautobahn Stadtauswärts im Tunnelflughafen Tegel ist nach einem Unfall die linke Spur gesperrt. Tiergartenstraße des 17. Juni zwischen Brandenburger Tor und Jetzerkrabinstraße gibt es eine Vollsperrung bis zum 11. Ebenfalls komplett gesperrt ist die Ebertstraße am Brandenburger Tor. Grund ist das UEFA Champions League Festival. Und noch was zur S-Bahn. Auf der S8 fahren bis Betriebsschluss Busse statt Bahnen, und zwar zwischen Blankenburg und Hohen-Neuen-Dorf. Woche mal seit. Gute Fahrt!
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby. Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt......oder diesen Sound......dann hört doch mal den Fritz Soundgarden mit Maurice Geider. Immer sonntags ab 20 Uhr und im Radio.
Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de.
Tschüss Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon, das heißt einer der Blue Moone, wo Leute aus dem Chaos Computer Club oder dem Umfeld zu Gast sind und über Themen reden, die mit dem Internet zu tun haben. Heute geht es um zwei Jahre Snowden, was davon umgeblieben ist, was wir davon lernen konnten. Zu Gast sind Linus Neumann, Andre Meister und Anne Roth. Hallo und guten Abend noch mal, zum letzten Mal. Und zwei davon haben näher mit dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag zu tun. Andre Meister geht da als ganz normaler Bürger hin und bloggt dann reichhaltig drüber. Anne Roth ist da als Fachreferentin für die Linke, Teil dieses Ausschusses. Und Anne, du hast gerade erzählt, so ein bisschen von der Arbeit da, aber auch, dass du das als Werkzeug sozusagen nicht ganz das ist, was man sich vielleicht wünscht, aber doch ein paar erstaunliche Ergebnisse zutage gebracht haben. Was sind denn das für diese Ergebnisse, wo du sagst, okay, das ist ganz cool, dass wir das herausgefunden haben?
Na, es gibt eine ganze Menge so, ich schreibe mich so ein bisschen das Kleinkram zu nennen, aber letztlich, so wenn man das große Ganze betrachtet, sind das kleinere Erkenntnisse, die vorher zumindest nicht so richtig nachweisbar waren, was es an Rechtsbrüchen durch den BND gibt. Also eins davon zum Beispiel macht die Runde als Weltraumtheorie. Das ist rausgekommen, als der BND hat eine eigene Datenschützerin und als Frau Dr. F die Datenschützerin des BND, vor dem Ausschuss erklärt hat, dass sie einen Dissens hat mit dem Präsidenten des BND, weil sie festgestellt hat, als eben Datenschutzbeauftragte, dass alle Daten, die der BND an Satelliten erfasst, vom BND nicht als dem BND-Gesetz unterfallend betrachtet werden, was aus ihrer Perspektive deswegen eine Rolle spielt, weil dann Datenschutzregelungen für diese Daten angewandt werden müssten. Und Schindler und der BND-Präsident sind aber der Meinung, Schindler ist der Präsident des Bundesnachrichtendienstes, mit dem sie das, so hat sie das beschrieben, auch versucht hat auszudiskutieren, aber er ist halt der Chef und hat sich damit durchgesetzt, ist der Meinung, das sind Daten, das sind Daten, die nicht auf deutschem Boden erfasst werden, sondern eben im Weltraum und deswegen gilt das BND-Gesetz nicht und deswegen müssen wenigstens diese Datenschutzregelungen auf diese Daten nicht angewandt werden. Das klingt jetzt ziemlich juristisch und so ziemlich spitzfindig, aber hat natürlich durchaus Auswirkungen. Sie hat auch erzählt beispielsweise, dass eine Reihe von Datenbanken durch den BND-Datensammlungen geführt werden, von denen es keine Dateianordnungen gibt, was auch aus Datenschutzperspektiven ein Problem ist. Das heißt, es ist nicht dokumentiert, was sind das für Daten in diesen Datenbanken, warum und wofür werden die geführt. Das ist eigentlich eine Vorschrift, die im Datenschutz auf jeden Fall immer für alle Dateien gilt. Dann gibt es noch so eine Theorie, das ist die Funktionsträger-Theorie, die ein anderer Zeuge dem Ausschuss offenbart hat. Und die bedeutet, dass Deutsche, und da sind wir ein bisschen bei der Frage von vorhin, gilt das jetzt wie so beschäftigt ihr euch nur mit deutschen Staatsbürgern und die Amerikaner nur mit Amerikanern, so sind halt die Gesetze hier im Moment. Und die schützen vor allen Dingen durch den Artikel 10 des Grundgesetzes, eben die Telekommunikation vor Überwachung von Deutschen. Und wiederum, das, was Andre vorhin gesagt hat, das ist, was die drei Verfassungsrichter muniert haben und gesagt haben, G10 ist kein deutsches Grundrecht, sondern ein Grundrecht, das gilt für alle Menschen, aber das wird von der Bundesregierung anders gesehen. Und es ist ihnen auch völlig egal, dass selbst das CSU-Mitglied Papier, ehemaliger Bundesverfassungsgerichtspräsident, der Meinung ist, dass man das so nicht machen kann. Dann ist also der Bundesregierung egal. Deswegen gilt das nur für Deutsche in der aktuellen Auslegung der Bundesregierung und damit auch das BND. Und das wird insofern auch noch ausgehebelt, dass Deutsche beispielsweise, die sich im Ausland befinden und dort für zum Beispiel nicht deutsche Firmen arbeiten oder als Journalisten für CNN oder so, nicht als deutsche Staatsbürger durch das G10-Grundrecht geschützt sind, sondern als Funktionsträger gesehen werden. Und damit zumindest, weil es ihre nicht-private Kommunikation, also ihre berufliche Kommunikation, die nicht geschützt werden, obwohl sie Deutsche sind, gibt es auch eine ganze Menge von Juristen, die sagen, das ist völlig absurd, diese Interpretation, aber der BND finde das voll okay. Und so von dieser Kategorie von Sachen, da könnte ich jetzt noch reihenweise aufziehen. Ich sehe schon, Zeit haben wir nicht, aber da gibt es echt noch eine Menge von Sachen, die bisher einfach nicht so richtig deutlich belegt waren. Ich finde das einerseits wichtig, dass das rauskommt. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich so ein bisschen Sorge. Die SPD hat damit jetzt schon angefangen, ein Gesetz zu erarbeiten, wo die Weltraumtheorie aufgeräumt werden soll, dass sozusagen diese illegalen Praktiken des BND jetzt einfach im Nachhinein durch Gesetze legitimiert werden. Das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht das, was mein Ziel und unser Ziel mit dem Untersuchungsausschuss ist. Da glaube ich ist auch wichtig, dass viel Öffentlichkeit dazu da ist und aufpasst, dass jetzt nicht einfach im Nachhinein so die Sicherheitsgesetze so ein bisschen angepasst werden. Nichtsdestotrotz finde ich aber gut, dass das überhaupt erst mal untersucht wird.
Okay, also es gibt Ergebnisse, die dann möglicherweise wiederum für zweifelhafte Dinge benutzt werden. Aber okay, immerhin, Andre, du als externer Beobachter, wie ist deine Einschätzung, was diesen Untersuchungsausschuss angeht? Ist das ein probates Mittel?
Ja, tatsächlich wird dort nicht die Revolution stattfinden. Das muss woanders geschehen. Immerhin haben wir jetzt in den Nachrichten gelernt, dass wir über das Internet den sekundenschnellen Jugendlichen überall auf der Welt erreichen und beeinflussen können. Das tun wir auch in Radiosendungen wie dieser. Trotzdem finde ich auch, dass der Ausschuss einige coole Sachen ans Licht gebracht hat. Auch wenn wahrscheinlich die ursprünglich von den Snowden-Enthüllungen sich abgeleitete Auftrag, tatsächlich was über die Five Eyes, über die Geheimnisse der USA und das GCHQ und so weiter zu erfahren, leider derzeit ziemlich dünn ist, weil im Gegensatz zu dem BND kann der Bundestag die nicht um Akten oder Zeugen zwingen, aber immerhin ist es gut, auch über den BND und die obskuren Rechtstheorien, die die da haben, ein bisschen was zu lernen über die Operationen, wie die operieren. Und wenn in der Bildzeitung in den US-Geheimdienstler sagt, dass die deutsche Regierung und der Ausschuss gefährlicher ist, als die Snowden-Enthüllungen, dann muss der schon irgendwas richtig machen. Andererseits sehe ich auch die Gefahr als Berufspessimist. Wir hatten in der Vergangenheit schon öfters mal Geheimdienst-Skandale in den 70ern, in den USA mit dem sogenannten Church-Committee. Und dann aber auch Anfang der Nuller 2001, der EU-Bericht zu dem globalen Überwachungssystem Echelon, wo genau das eigentlich schon alles drin stand. Da wurde schon mal an zwei Punkten der Geschichte vehement davor gewarnt, dass wir in ein alles Überwachungsnetz abgleiten könnten. Aber trotzdem ist nichts passiert. Im Gegenteil, es ist sogar noch schlimmer geworden. Und mit den derzeitigen Mehrheitsverhältnissen, also ich sehe das auch so kritisch wie Anna, wir müssen aufpassen, dass aus den Erkenntnissen, die wir jetzt aus Snowden und aus diesem Ausschuss ziehen, dass wir dann auch die richtigen Schlussfolgerungen ableiten und nicht, wie es eben aus der SPD zu hören ist, dass jetzt einfach legalisieren wollen, was vorher illegal war. Sondern wir sollten uns als Gesellschaft überlegen, was ist Überwachung? Wie wollen wir in einer freien demokratischen Gesellschaft miteinander umgehen? Wie hindert Überwachung Leute an der freien Entfaltung, an der freien Meinungsbildung, an freien Meinungsäußerung? Und was ist ein adäquates Mittel, damit umzugehen und dann Antworten da zu finden?
Jetzt ist ja die politische Aufarbeitung die eine Sache. Jetzt stelle ich mir gerade eine Frage, weil wir ja gerade auch gesagt haben, da sind auch Rechtsbrüche oder zumindest haben, gibt es Experten, die sagen, da finden Rechtsbrüche statt? Und da möchte ich eine Frage von Twitter weitergeben. Frufus fragt, könntest du mal fragen, warum die Regierung beziehungsweise der BND noch nicht in Grund und Boden geklagt wurden? Das ist ja tatsächlich jetzt, was man denkt, okay, wenn es Experten gibt, die sagen, das ist ein Rechtsbruch, dann könnte man noch vielleicht mal irgendwo klagen. Geht das überhaupt? Also kann man den BND verklagen? Und wenn ja, wird das gemacht?
Es wird gemacht. Es passiert in den USA, es passiert in Großbritannien und es passiert in Deutschland und jetzt auch in der ganzen EU. Also wir hatten schon vor den Snowden-Enthüllungen Leute, die in Deutschland gegen den BND geklagt haben, weil der BND in seiner jährlichen Statistik angegeben hat, 37 Millionen E-Mails im Jahr zu überwachen und dass Leuten ziemlich viel groß vorkam. Wie wir hören, ist das jetzt alles total untertrieben, diese offiziellen Zahlen. Aber da haben schon vorher Leute dagegen geklagt, gegen die anlasslose Massenüberwachung einmal alles aus bestimmten Kommunikationssträngen zu nehmen. Das hat jetzt neu an Fahrt aufgenommen. Immer mehr Leute denken darüber nachzuklagen. Der Dezix, der große Internetprovider in Frankfurt, hat angekündigt, gegen Überwachungsanordnungen zu klagen. Wir haben jetzt den Peter Pilz, einen grünen Politiker in Österreich, der in Österreich Strafanzeige gegen die Deutsche Telekom und den BND gestellt hat, weil er in Akten gefunden hat, dass der BND auf Anweisungen der NSA bestimmte Telekommunikationsleitungen von Österreich in den Rest der Welt abgeschnuschelt hat und nachdem er das in Österreich getan hat, gibt es jetzt auch entsprechende Strafanzeigen in Luxemburg, in der Schweiz und heute in den Niederlanden. Es wird immer mehr geklagt. Unsere Freunde von Privacy International in England hatten sogar schon erste Erfolge vor Gericht. Da hat ein Gericht gesagt, die Datenübermittlung der NSA an den britischen Geheimdienst war bis zu dem Urteil, also Dezember 2014, komplett illegal. Die dürfen das quasi nicht mehr verwenden. Dann wurde natürlich sofort nach dem Urteil das Gesetz geändert, damit das jetzt nicht mehr illegal ist. Trotzdem kann man denen da so ein paar Nadelstiche versetzen, auch wenn das natürlich nicht die Lösung ist. Denn wie wir sehen, interpretieren die sich ihre Gesetze nicht nur heimlich um, sondern sie scheißen komplett drauf. Deswegen ist das rechtliche Vorgehen nur ein Baustein in dem kompletten Arsenal, was wir haben.
So, dann müssen wir jetzt, also beinahe auch schon wieder zum Schluss kommen, deswegen die Frage, wie wird es denn jetzt weitergehen? Ich weiß, das ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig, in die Zukunft zu schauen, aber wir haben ja sozusagen so ein paar Dinge besprochen, die so ein bisschen funktionieren, wenigstens, und jetzt ist die Frage, was wird in Zukunft passieren? Also ein pessimistisches Bild, das ich aus dieser Sendung ableiten kann, ist, es wird politisch und gerichtlich so ein bisschen Aufklärung geben. Und das wird die Politik dazu benutzen, um Gesetze zu erlassen, die das, was jetzt an Massenbewachung schon stattfindet, einfach zu legalisieren. Und dann leben wir in ein, zwei, drei, fünf Jahren in einer schönen neuen Welt, wo wir alle sozusagen ganz legal überwacht werden. Das ist sozusagen das Worst-Case-Denarii, was ich jetzt ableiten könnte aus dem, was ihr mir heute erzählt habt.
Also ich mach mir, ich denke bei sowas immer an den Geschichtsunterricht an amerikanischen Highschools. Den habe ich auch mal genossen. Und irgendwann wird ja diese Snowden-Affäre zwangsläufig auch in diesem Geschichtsunterricht landen. Der fängt also, die amerikanische Geschichte ist nicht so lang, die fängt dann damit an, dass ihnen das Land von den Bewohnern geschenkt wurde und dann sind ganz viele Afrikaner gekommen, um ihnen zu helfen. So ungefähr wird da die Geschichte erzählt. Und ich frage mich, wie dieser Konflikt dann irgendwann mal in amerikanischen Geschichtsunterrichtsstunden behandelt wird. Und ich glaube, bisher wäre die Geschichte so, oder meine größte Sorge ist, dass man sagt so, als das den Menschen erzählt wurde, dass der Staat sie zu ihrer Sicherheit beschützt, war das ein Skandal. Da haben sie sich gegen gewehrt. Das wollten sie nicht. Sie konnten noch nicht verstehen, dass das alles notwendig ist, um uns vor den bösen Terroristen zu beschützen. Gleichzeitig glaube ich aber, dass die faktische Veränderung in der Gesellschaft, also was sich an neuen Produkten durchsetzt, was sich an neuen Bewusstsein durchsetzt, vielleicht sich gar nicht so sehr in den politischen Konsequenzen niederschlagen wird, die ich ebenso wichtig finde, die ich mir auch wünsche und die ich auch mit sehr großem Genuss gerade verfolge. Wenn also eine Kanzlerin, die im letzten Jahr noch einen von Abhörern unter Freunden, das geht gar nicht, erzählt hat, jetzt als Chefin der Überwacher enttarnt ist, die genau das mit anderen Ländern tun. Aber ich hoffe natürlich, dass diese Geschichte, dass dieser Vorfall in die Geschichte eingehen wird, als ein Paradigmenwechsel zu einer Gesellschaft, die wenigstens vorsichtiger geworden ist und die sich gewisser Risiken bewusst geworden ist und die hoffentlich sei es mit Gerichtsverfahren, sei es mit Selbstschutz, sei es mit anderen politischen Mitteln außer parlamentarischer Natur dafür gesorgt hat, dass dieser Massenüberwachung ein Einhalt geboten wird. Denn ich denke, was wir häufig außer Acht lassen, ist, wie unsere Gesellschaft sich nur in den vergangenen 20 Jahren in diese digitalisierte Form geschoben hat. Und dieser Prozess ist ja noch gar nicht zu Ende. Das heißt, wir werden alle immer mehr Aspekte unseres Lebens immer tiefer digitalisieren, immer mehr von Netzwerken durchdringen lassen. Und wir haben da große Potenziale für unsere Gesellschaft und fürchterliche Überwachungs- und Machtpotenziale. Denn das ist das, was am Ende mit dieser Überwachung einhergeht. Und nicht das Risiko des Einzelnen, sondern die Machtkonzentration auf wenige, die diese Gesellschaft manipulieren, leiten und kontrollieren können.
Was ich mir jetzt gerade frage, wenn man über diese Überwachungskanäle redet, dann gibt es ja immer so zwei Extreme in der Zukunft. Das eine ist so, wir landen in diesem voll überwachten, total schlimmen Staat. Das andere ist so, Geheimdienste werden abgeschafft. Niemand weiß mehr irgendwas über irgendjemanden, das der nicht völlig freiwillig hergibt. Ist auch vorstellbar, dass es so einen Mittelweg gibt, also dass man ab jetzt immer davon ausgehen kann, die Geheimdienste machen auf jeden Fall mehr, als ihnen erlaubt ist. Aber wir haben sowohl technisch als auch politisch die Möglichkeiten, sie zumindest so zu pisaken und zu ärgern, dass sie nicht ganz unkontrolliert sind. Und das ist sozusagen, dass wir weiterhin in so einem Mittelzustand durch die Gegend schweben, mit Überwachung, aber auch mit ein bisschen Wehrhaftigkeit.
Also ehrlich gestanden glaube ich nicht an den Mittelwegen, muss ich echt sagen. Wobei ich auch keine Utopie im Kopf habe, wo das denn hinführen soll, weil glaube ich momentan wirklich nur ganz wenige Leute sich trauen, tatsächlich realistisch zu finden und sich vorzustellen, eine Welt ohne Geheimdienste. Ich finde aber die Geheimdienste, wie wir sie haben und wie sie sich benehmen und immer schon benehmen und auch die Argumente, die jetzt gerade viel zu lesen sind, die da heißen, jetzt werde doch mal realistisch, hat immer schon Spione gegeben und die wird's immer geben und die halten sich nicht ein Gesetz, das ist nun mal so und irgendwie alle spionieren gegen alle und jetzt kommt auch mal auf den Boden, hier und reißt euch ein bisschen zusammen und nehmt das richtig hin. Ich weigere mich ein bisschen, das so zu sehen. Für mich glaube ich war so und da sind wir noch mal beim Thema der Sendung auch so ein wirklich Schlüsselmoment in Citizen 4, als Edward Snowden sagt, für ihn der Moment umzudenken und zu überlegen, Whistleblower zu werden, war als er realisiert hat, dass das Internet, mit dem er aufgewachsen ist, das Freiheit symbolisiert hat, Freiheit der Kommunikation ausprobieren zu können, freie Räume zu haben, Sachen selber gestalten zu können, dass das plötzlich total in Gefahr war und umkippt in einen totalen Überwachungsstaat, aber eine Totalüberwachung, die noch viel schlimmer ist, als das, was wir vorher hatten. Und das ist im Grunde auch das, was mich antreibt, wenn du nach dem Ausblick fragst, wenn ich mir denke, wir sind im Moment an einem Punkt in der Geschichte, wo alles, was an demokratischen Elementen mal entwickelt wurde, auch nach der deutschen Geschichte und so weiter, Grundgesetz etc. völlig zurückgedreht wird. Diese Überwachung, wie sie machen, Massenüberwachung, wie sie durch die Geheimdienste implementiert wird gerade, werden die Meinungsfreiheit und Pressefreiheit vollständig zerstören. Es wird nichts mehr davon übrig bleiben, wenn wir das so geschehen lassen. Und jetzt werde ich vielleicht so ein bisschen pathetisch, aber die Vorstellung, dass mich in irgendwann 20 Jahren meine Kinder oder Enkel mal fragen, wieso habt ihr denn nichts gemacht, als das stattgefunden hat? Wieso habt ihr euch nicht dagegen gewehrt? Wieso habt ihr euch das alles wegnehmen lassen? Motivieren mich dazu, zu versuchen, was geht, um das irgendwie aufzuhalten, weil ich das nicht akzeptieren kann.
Die werden sich doch niemals trauen, die Frage überhaupt zu stellen.
André, willst du auch nochmal in dieses Klagehorn stoßen?
Ja, ich wollte das echt nicht als Klage gesehen haben, sondern eher als Ding, irgendwie wir müssen jetzt was machen. Dass also einfach sich zurücklehnen und denken, wird schon, irgendwer regeln geht nicht.
Also ich bin ja Berufspessimist, aber tatsächlich möchte ich mich an den letzten Satz von Anna anschließen. Also wir befinden uns in einem gesellschaftlichen Aushandlungsprozess und wir haben jetzt ein Fenster der Möglichkeiten, wie es so schön heißt. Jetzt sind die Fakten auf dem Tisch. Jetzt ist der Skandal aktuell. Wir haben zwei Jahresnoden. Wir haben ein Jahr Untersuchungsausschuss. Wir erfahren immer mehr, wie Geheimdienste ja Gesetze aktiv brechen, die komplette Menschheit überwachen und demokratisch einfach von Definition her nicht zu kontrollieren sind. Also wir haben jetzt die Möglichkeit, uns dagegen zu wehren und eine demokratische Gesellschaft, wie wir uns vorstellen, stattdessen zu entfalten, die eben ohne die Schere im Kopf, das wird ja sowieso alles überwacht und kann gegen mich verwendet werden, funktionieren kann. Deswegen finde ich schon zwei Jahresnoden, ein Jahr Ausschuss. Wir sollten uns alle mehr einbringen. Man kann ruhig mal zu so einer Ausschusssitzung gehen. Oder man kann auch einfach mal zu einer Demo gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung gehen. Jetzt kommt die Regierung auf die Idee ausgerechnet jetzt zum Thema unserer Sendung, irgendwie die anlasslose Massenüberwachung nicht nur von Geheimdiensten hinzunehmen, sondern jetzt auch für ganz normale Polizeibehörden, für stinknormale Drogendelikte auszuweiten, mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung einmal die komplette Menschheit in Deutschland zu überwachen und Bewegungsprofile von jedem zu erstellen. Und man kann sich so aus einbringen, ob es jetzt auch eine Demo gehen ist, mal zum Ausschuss gehen ist oder einfach mal den Abgeordneten der Wahl die Meinung sagen. Wir sind einen gesellschaftlichen Aushändlungsprozess. Wahrscheinlich werden wir in naher Zukunft nicht alle Geheimdienste abgeschafft haben. Ich wäre aber auch sehr froh, in 20 Jahren nicht in einer dystopischen Sci-Fi-Zukunft aufzuwachen, wo er alles verloren ist.
Puh, na ich hoffe, wir schaffen das noch. Ich habe noch eine kleine Detailfrage, die ich euch zum Abschluss stellen möchte. Und das ist, ich habe jetzt, weil jetzt immer, es kam jetzt dieser Schere im Kopfbegriff. Also es gibt schon Überwachung und deswegen gibt es die Schere im Kopf. Und im Chat zur Sendung hat gerade jemand gesagt, na er hätte die schon bei sich. Entdeckt ihr das bei euch auch? Dass ihr schon, dass ihr manchmal denkt, okay, das könnte jetzt irgendwo auftauchen. Und wenn ja, was würdet ihr empfehlen, wie man damit umgeht? Soll man dann das wirklich verbergen und der Schere stattgeben und sagt so, nee, jetzt erst recht, ich mache es trotzdem. Oder gerade deswegen?
Jetzt erst recht.
Also wenn wir unsere Freiheiten nicht ausleben, dann werden wir sie erst recht verlieren.
Na ich, das hat ja Linus vorhin schon angedeutet, ich habe das Problem mit der Überwachung schon ein bisschen länger und kenne diese Schere im Kopf auch ganz gut. Ich glaube, dieses einfach jetzt erst recht ist eigentlich die richtige Richtung. Aber das ist nicht immer so ganz einfach. Ich glaube, man muss ja am letzten Endes dann auch überlegen. Ich habe da kein Rezept zu. Aber es gibt sie und es ist, glaube ich, besser darüber nachzudenken, dass es sie gibt und wie wir mit ihr umgehen wollen, als einfach so zu tun, als gäbe es sie nicht. Und als kämen wir damit schon klar.
Ich glaube, wir dürfen uns von unseren Utopäen irgendwie nicht verabschieden und müssen halt steif gegenhalten.
Doch Revolution.
Dann danke ich euch, Linus, Andre und Anne, für diese Einblicke in zwei Jahren Snowden. Sehr interessant. Ihr könnt die Sendung auf jeden Fall auch noch als Podcast hören. Er scheint im Laufe der Nacht auf fritz.de, später dann auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Traditionell ist es so, dass am Ende der Sendung der Vertreter des Chaos Computer Clubs noch Termine ankündigt. Herr Neumann, hätten Sie da noch etwas für die geneigten Hörer?
Wir hätten da so eine Gulasch-Programmier-Nacht. Vom 4.6. bis 7.6. im Zentrum für Kunst- und Medientechnologie und der Hochschule für Gestaltung, beide ansässig in Karlsruhe. Die Gulasch-Programmier-Nacht wird ausgerichtet vom Entropia e.V. Das ist ein Erfahrungskreis des CCC in Karlsruhe ansässig. Dort gibt es Hackengulasch-Vorträge, Cloud sogar, Chunk-Workshops, Lounge-Mate und Spaß am Gerät. Ich habe gerade schon ein bisschen im Fahrplan gestöbert. Sieht interessant aus, viel Technik, viel Kultur. Denke ich auf jeden Fall eine Reise wert für diejenigen, die nicht ortsansässig sind. Und dann haben wir natürlich das Camp, das CCC Camp. Ich glaube, es ist vom 13. bis 17. offiziell. Ich werde da ein bisschen früher anreisen. August? August, genau. August. Da fahren wir dann alle auf den Acker, zelten und versuchen, uns vor dem bösen Stern am Himmel zu schützen, der unsere Haut verbrennt.
Wird es dort auch Internet geben?
Es wird dort Internet geben, es wird dort Schunk geben. Also Wasserversorgung müssen wir noch mal gucken.
Du wirst auch noch von den Demos sprechen, die es gibt jetzt, oder?
Nein, das machst ja dann du.
Weil Camp ist super und macht viel Spaß. Und vorher gibt es aber noch eine Reihe von Demonstrationen, unter anderem gegen den BND in Berlin diesen Samstag um 14 Uhr. Die Rechtsanwälte gegen Totalüberwachung am Kanzlerinamt um 16 Uhr. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer genau am BND. Es gibt im Moment eine ganze Tour. Freiheit statt Angst, die durch verschiedene Städte tourt. In Frankfurt ist am Samstag auch eine Demo. Und es ist nicht so, dass nichts stattfinde. Geht hin und zeigt, dass ihr was dagegen habt.
Also man kann sie politisch engagieren und gleichzeitig Spaß haben. Dann nochmal vielen Dank. Ich wünsche euch eine gute Nacht. Um nur noch zu sagen, heute mehr denn je. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Lasst euch nicht überwachen. Und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.